welcome to this exciting video course
brought to you by the renowned course
creator anyakubo in this comprehensive
chat GTP course we'll dive deep into the
world of the openai API exploring its
diverse capabilities and potential
applications throughout this journey
you'll Master the ins and outs of the
open AI API starting with creating your
very own Chachi PT clone which is a
powerful language model that can
generate human-like text based on your
specific needs next we'll dive into the
fascinating realm of Dolly and AI driven
image generator that can produce
visually striking and imaginative images
with just a few lines of code finally
you'll create a SQL generator a
game-changing tool that can help you
generate and optimize complex SQL
queries in no time with Anya's engaging
and Hands-On teaching style you'll find
yourself immersed in the world of AI
learning not only the theory but also
practical techniques that can be applied
to real world projects by the end of
this course you'll be equipped with the
Knowledge and Skills to harness the
power of the open AI API to
revolutionize your work and open up a
world of creativity and Innovation
welcome to this extensive chat GPT
course if you're a developer looking to
integrate natural language processing
into your applications you've come to
the right place chat GPT is a powerful
language model created by open AI
capable of generating human-like text
responses to a wide range of prompts
with API that powers it you can
integrate cutting-edge technology into
applications and unlock a whole new
world of possibilities my name is Anu
Cuba and I'm a software developer as
well as course creator here on free code
Camp as well as on my own channel in
this course I'm going to walk you
through each section of the openai API
documentation I'm going to show you how
to access the API uses various endpoints
and use them in various real-life
projects that we will be building
together including this chat GPT cloning
JavaScript a version in react for
comparison and AI generator in
JavaScript as well as one react
utilizing the open AI node.js Library as
well as an AI SQL query generator that
will generate SQL for you based on the
prompts you give by the end of this
course you'll be able to confidently
take the open AI API and integrate it
into any application that you build to
fully utilize its powerful natural
language processing capabilities if you
want to skip to a section then please
feel free we've given timestamps in this
course for you to be able to navigate
from one to the other just be careful as
we will be building on Knowledge from
the previous section and using it in the
sections that follow okay so what are we
waiting for a basic understanding of
JavaScript and react is necessary for
this course but if you don't have it
please feel free to follow along anyway
and then fill in the gaps later on
just like most apis the open AI API uses
API keys for authentication in this
section I'm going to show you how to get
your own API key for when it comes to
communicating with the API from
applications that we will be building
remember make sure not to share your API
key or publish it somewhere public this
is because if someone takes it they
could potentially use up all your free
credits or rack up loads and loads on
your credit card if you have a credit
card attached to it this also includes
exposing any client-side code by this I
mean building an app without a backend
and deploying it onto the internet the
code in this case will be visible simply
by inspecting it like so someone will
then be able to go and take it from here
for their own use to use this key safely
requests must be routed through a
back-end server where your API key can
be securely loaded from an environment
variable or Key Management Service okay
so let's look at how to get your own API
key as well as generate new ones if you
need
okay so let's do it let's start off by
getting our API keys so first off just
start off on openai.com and make sure
you're signed in and Under menu go ahead
and click under the developer portal and
just click overview this should take you
to
platform.openai.com forward slash
overview perhaps the UI has changed but
essentially this is where you need to be
next just go ahead and click on your
username as you can see here my username
is freecodecamp editorial I'm just going
to go ahead and click on that and view
API keys and there we go
so as you can see here there is already
one secret key let's get to creating a
new one so all I'd have to do is click
on this gray button right here and I can
choose to name this if I wish so let's
go ahead and name this my demo key and
just create a secret key and there we go
now don't forget to copy this and save
it somewhere safe why I'm just going to
go ahead and click done we cannot view
that API key anymore so if you didn't
save it well you're gonna have to create
a new key so let's go ahead and delete
that one because I didn't save it so
let's revoke it and all you're gonna
have to do is click on this little
button right here and revoke the key and
let's create a new one so I'm just going
to create a new key again and let's call
this my demo key again and this time
let's create the secret key copy this
save it somewhere safe and click done
now if you are worried that someone has
stolen your API key or perhaps you might
have published it out onto the internet
you can revoke it as we just saw so you
would just click revert key and then
that API key will not work anymore
okay and why do we not want it to work
anymore because if someone has indeed
stolen your API key they can potentially
if you click under usage right here use
up all your free credits so as you can
see here here are the three credits that
we have used for the month we don't want
someone taking our tokens right or worse
if we have a credit card attached to
under billing you can attach payment
methods they can also potentially rack
up loads and loads on your credit card
bills so keep those API Keys safe
the open AI API is powered by diverse
set of models with different
capabilities and price points at the
time of writing the newest we can use is
gpt4 it is a set of models that improve
on GPT 3.5 and can understand as well as
generate natural language or code we
will be using this model as well as
those previous versions the most as it's
the most universal others of note art
Dali which is an AI system that can
create realistic images and art from a
description in natural language we can
make requests to create numerous images
of a certain size edit an existing image
or create variations of a user provided
image if we wish we will be using this
in our projects that are coming up soon
there is also whisper which is a general
purpose speech recognition model it is
trained on a large data set of diverse
audio and is also a multi-task model
that can perform multilingual speech
recognition as well as speech
translation and language identification
in fact here is a full list of models
that are currently to our disposal let's
get to understanding some of these
better next
now that we have our API key and have
understood the models that are available
to us let's go to writing some requests
these two things are super necessary for
this next part so make sure you have
both first up we're going to look at
text completion with text completion we
can generate or manipulate text by this
I mean it was literally built to
complete your sentences so if you write
Oscar Wilde be yourself everyone else is
it will return already taken with high
probability you can also ask it to
complete from nothing based on text
prompts I can write something like come
up with a name from my friend darius's
pizza shop and I will come back with
this
now it is likely you'll get a different
completion each time even if your prompt
does not change this is because the API
is non-deterministic by default by this
I mean it is not possible to guess what
will happen we can actually change this
by setting a temperature to make it more
deterministic but we will cover that
when the time is right
so let's try it out here's the endpoint
we will be using for this it is a post
request for those of you who don't know
what a post request is now will be the
time to check out a tutorial on HTTP
request methods to fully get the most
out of the next steps or if you are
feeling adventurous please car along
anyway and fill in the gaps when you
want to now there are a few things that
we can put in a request body along with
our post request and here they are the
only one that is not optional is the
model that we are going to use so let's
whack that in I'm going to go ahead and
use text DaVinci 003 for this demo as a
reminder here are some of the models we
can use although keep in mind that not
all of them can be used for text
completion next we are going to put in a
prompt this is essentially a string or
an array that we are going to pass over
to the API to generate completions for
in this case I'm going to pause the
string of hello how are you today
we can also choose to add a suffix which
takes strings which comes after a
completion of inserted text but I'm not
going to do that for this demo
next up we can optionally add Max tokens
this will take an integer that will
represent the maximum number of tokens
to generate in the completion tokens are
what all the models use to process text
there are essentially common sequences
of characters found in text
the models understand the statistical
relationship between these tokens and
Excel are producing the next token in a
sequence of tokens I know this is hard
to comprehend so let's take an example
to understand how the API would tokenize
a piece of text as when I see the total
count of tokens in that piece of text so
let's go ahead and put in the string of
hello how are you today you will see
seven tokens are used here according to
the API now let's try another one let's
try what is the meaning of life and can
you write an essay about it now this is
of course a little bit more complex so
you will see the number of tokens that
will use were a total of 15. as a
general rule one token generally
corresponds to roughly four characters
of text for common English text this
translates to roughly three quarters of
a word so in other words a hundred
tokens equals roughly 75 words the token
count of your prompt plus Max tokens
cannot see the model's context length
most models have context length of 2048
tokens except for the newest models
which can support
4069. next we have the option to put in
temperature as a number we can write a
value from zero to two higher values
like 0.8 will make the output more
random while lower values like 0.2 will
make it more focused and deterministic
and as an alternative we can also use
top P which will use nuclear sampling as
opposed to sampling with temperature it
is recommended using this or temperature
but not both in this case the model
considers the result of the token with
top P probability Mass so 0.1 means only
the tokens comprising the top 10
probability Mass are considered next we
have n n allows us to set how many
completions to generate for each prompt
by passing an integer value doing this
we'll understand we take more tokens so
just keep that in mind
we can also pass through user which will
represent our end user to help Monitor
and detect abuse so these are the most
popular ones used I'm just going to show
you the other ones briefly to show you
they exist but not going into them in
any detail okay so all of these along
with ones we just covered can go into
the request body along with our post
requests and the only one that is
required is the model that we're going
to use
got it good let's try it out
okay so what I've done is just set up a
super simple project I have done this in
my code editor I've just created an
index HTML file with some boilerplate
code and then I've linked up the app.js
file using this script tag so that's all
I've done next I've just created that
object as file and this is where I am
going to write that request it's going
to be a post request to the end point
that we saw passing through all the
options so let's do it I'm going to do
it this way first and then I'm going to
show you how to do this with a curl
command
so first off well let's actually do this
all the function so I'm going to call
this function fetch data just like so
and this is going to be an async
function as we're going to be using the
await keyword in here because we're
going to be dealing with the fetch API
so we're gonna have to wait for this to
get resolved so we're gonna have to
await the response of this okay and then
we're going to save this to whatever we
want let's save it to the cons response
now I'm just going to minimize this for
us we can see this a little bit better
now the URL that we need or we can just
take this from the documentation it's
going to be
this right so just make sure yours looks
the same and you're not going to chat
completions we're just going to the
completions endpoint this time next
we're going to pass through our options
so my options well we're going to pass
you the method as we know this is a post
method and now we're going to pass
through some headers as well so the
headers that I am going to pass through
well we're going to have to pass through
our API key and for that I'm going to
use authorization and now because we are
well you can put in the string directly
in here but most of you will probably
want to save your API key somewhere safe
so use backticks so that we can use text
essentially or a string
and then put in some code and to put in
code we use this syntax so you get your
dollar sign your Kali braces and then
we're going to put in our API key here
so this is going to be a const let's
define it up here const API key
and just go ahead and paste your API key
in here as a string so that is my one
that I will be revoking and we're ready
to carry on now let's also Define our
content type
so content type and we're going to be
working with Json so we're going to do
application
because we're going to have to pass
through a body of stuff and that stuff
is well it's the options that we saw so
here's our body I'm gonna wrap it in
Json string of five
just like so and create an object my
object is going to hold everything we
want to pass on to open Ai and that is
the model on this occasion I'm going to
use text the Vinci z003 when we get to
doing the chat completions we will be
using chat gtb4 and chat GTP 3.5 but for
this one we can just go ahead and use
text DaVinci because we can't use the
others now I'm going to use prompt and
let's just go ahead and hard code a
prompt hello how are you today
just like so and we can also pass
through the max tickets if we wish okay
I'm going to go ahead and do it as
that's what we saw in the example and
I'm going to go with seven
so the only thing that is required are
these two and this one is optional
just make sure there's Max token 7. okay
so those are all our options okay and
now we're going to get the response
and we're going to get it to Json but uh
oh this is also an async method which
means we need to wait for that to come
back and let's save it as something I
want to save as data and now let's just
console log new data okay that's all
we're going to do so let's call this
function so we just want this to be
called when we open up the web page so
let's go ahead and copy the part the
absolute path to this paste it and like
so and now I'm just going to inspect
this page and look on the console log
and ta-da that is essentially our data
that's what we're console logging out
and if you look under choices so there's
objects you use dot notation to get this
you'd go dot choices and you go into the
array and you can see the text that has
come back it says I'm doing well great
so that is how you would do it in
JavaScript this is what we're going to
be doing and one of the projects we're
also going to be doing this in the back
end where we store our API Keys safely
however for those of you who don't
really want to build a project you just
want like a simple response in a matter
of seconds I'm going to show you how to
do this with a cow command next
okay so maybe let's just get rid of that
and get up
my terminal
okay so here is our car command as you
can see we've got the end point right
here make sure yours looks the same so
it's not going to forward slash chat or
anything like that we've got the content
type we've got the authorization so
let's go ahead and replace that API key
right here so I'm just going to delete
all of this including the dollar sign
and I'm just going to paste mine in like
so so that's what yours should look like
we've got a model here we have say this
is a test let's go ahead and replace
this with hello how
are you question mark and we've got the
max tokens there we also have the
temperature
so let's go ahead and run this I'm just
going to hit enter
and there we go so this is essentially
what we saw coming back to us in the
browser we've got I'm doing well so two
ways to do this please play around with
these have fun and when you're ready
let's move on
open AI models can do pretty much
anything from writing Original Stories
to performing complex text analysis
because they can do so many things you
have to be explicit and telling them
what they need to do showing and not
telling is often the key to writing a
good prompt here are three basic
guidelines to creating effective prompts
so first off we have it show and tell
make it clear what you want either
through instructions examples or a
combination of the two if you are the
model to rank a list of items in
alphabetical order or to classify a
paragraph by sentiment show it that's
what you want next up we have providing
quality data if you're trying to build a
classifier or get the model to follow a
pattern make sure that there are enough
examples also make sure to proofread
your examples the model is usually smart
enough to see through basic spelling
mistakes and give you a response but I
also might assume that this is
intentional and it can affect the
response and finally check your settings
the temperature and top B settings that
we covered earlier control had
deterministic the model is in generating
a response if you're asking it for a
response where there's only one right
answer that you'd want to set these
lower if you're looking for more diverse
responses then you might want to set
them higher it is also worth knowing
that the number one mistake people use
with these settings is assuming that
their cleverness or creativity controls
okay so those are the three guidelines
you can use for writing effective
prompts please have a go at trying them
out and seeing if your prompts are
actually getting better responses by
applying these three basic guidelines to
them and once you're ready let's carry
on
okay so by now we would have looked at
types completions as well as how to
write effective prompts so let's get to
the meteor stuff we're going to look at
chat completions next track completions
will essentially allow you to have a
whole conversation with the open AI we
are going to do so by using the GPT 3.5
turbo model or the gpt4 model to a
different endpoint or specifically to
the open AI chat API with an open AI
chat API we can do such things as write
code suggest text for an email create AI
chat agent translate languages suggest
topics for talks and so much more we
will be using this API for our upcoming
projects this is because it can do
pretty much what the text completions
can do but of course ticket one step
further by initializing a whole
conversation and chat so we're already
covering all the bases by using this and
not only that gpg 3.5 turbo performs at
a similar capacity to text DaVinci 003
that we use in the 10 next completion
part of this course but at 10 of the
price per token so it makes sense for us
to use it really luckily for us I love
what we learned in the text completion
part of this course will be applied to
you too so as previously we will need
our API token and the model we want to
use for this we'll be using the
following endpoint and making a post
request to it so as you will see this
time it's forward slash chat forward
slash completions
next we put in our token as well as the
model we want to use so I would put in
my token and the model of GPT 3.5 turbo
or GPT 4. these two things aren't
required what is also required in this
case is the messages messages take an
array of objects in a specific chart
format to generate chat completions here
is an example of the array with an
object of the specific format in it it
has a row and a space with a prompt
content
outside of these required Fields all the
rest of these are optional I will not go
into them again as we already did this
in the text completion part of the
course if you would like a refresher on
what each of these mean in more detail
and how they can be used please go back
to the text completion section not far
behind this
okay so here we have our request let's
give it a whirl
okay so once again here is my project
I've just created two files an index
HTML file like so with a script tag and
I've licked my app.js file right here
which is going to hold our JavaScript
and our JavaScript is how we are going
to essentially make a fetch request a
post request to the open AI API
so let's do it I'm just going to
minimize this and once again let's write
a function I'm going to call the
function batch data just like so
and in here we're going to use the fetch
API and we're going to pass through two
things one is going to be the end point
and the second is going to be our option
so we're going to pass through with that
request
so the fetch keyword well it is an async
method so we're going to have to use the
await keyword but uh oh we can't use a
weight inside a function that is not
async so let's put that in right there
so two things we're going to have to put
in we're going to have to put the end
point that's right and the end point as
we know is this right here and the
options that we're going to pass through
we're going to pass through the method
and that is a post method the other
thing we're going to go off to pass
through is the headers because we're
going to have to pass through our API
key so once again let's put
authorization making sure to spell that
correctly and then I'm going to use
backtick once more so Bearer and I'm
going to pass through some code and that
code is just going to be the const of
our API key which I'm just going to
Define up here because you know if
you're doing this on the back end you
probably want to keep that API key in a
DOT EMV file for example like we will be
doing in the project
okay so our API key once again I'm just
going to paste that in I'm just going to
paste that in as a string for now
so that will now be essentially injected
into here so we've got our API key next
we need to define the content type we're
going to be working with Jason so I'm
going to do application Json
just like so
next we're going to have to pass through
the body and the body well we're going
to pass you an object but we're going to
wrap it in Json stringify so Json string
file like that so let's get that object
and just whack it in like so
so what things do we need to pass
through to our API well the first one is
the model let's go ahead and work with
gpg for this time and we're going to
pass through the messages the message is
this is different than the prompt than
we saw before it's going to be an array
and each message is essential object
it's going to take a row
the role in this case is going to be the
use that's going to be us and then the
content which I'm going to just hard
code is hello for now we can pass
through as many messages as we want
remember this is a chat so if you want
to pause through more messages you can
do just like so so if I want to say
hello
how are you in two separate messages
that I can that is an option I'll be
showing you how to do this in the
project part of the section for
knowledge just pass through one message
so once again that is my one message
represented by this object which has
these two things in there okay
so just so this is more readable I'm
just gonna put it like so and that is
all we need to pass through so those are
all our options so let's wait for this
and save it under response and then get
the response right after this has done
its thing so down here and let's get it
Json well oh this is an async method so
we're going to use the oh wait keyword
and await that Json let's save it under
data and I'm just gonna console log
data so let's call this right I'm gonna
get this and away at the bottom which is
cool this and that's
open this up in our browser so I'm going
to copy the path copy the absolute path
that in
spect the page go to the console log and
there's our object and those are our
choices so you get an array and then we
see the messages that come back this
time the role is from the assistant okay
because we're the user
and this time the assistant is saying
hello how can I help you today
great so we're already starting a chat
this is wonderful and once again for
those of you who don't really care about
you know building on app you just want
something quick let's look at the Carl
command to do so
so here is the car command once again
let's just go ahead and make sure that
URL is good that is correct and let's
replace this API key so I'm just going
to go ahead and delete all of this
including the dollar sign it's paste in
that API key let's also replace this
let's go ahead with gpt4 and then we can
now hello sure let's go ahead and hit
enter
and amazing so here we have the same
thing here's our content from the
assistant remember where the user this
is the assistant and it's saying hello
how can I help you today
great
great so now that we have understood how
to use chat completions I'm going to use
this API in our next two projects the
first project is going to be more aim
for beginners where we build out a
simple JavaScript project in JavaScript
HTML and CSS and we use the fetch API in
order to fetch data from this API using
the requests that we just built however
as we now know this will not be secure
this is because this is a front-end
project okay so if you do choose to
build this make sure to keep your API
Keys safe and don't publish this code
anywhere on GitHub or anywhere on the
internet it is for your personal use
next up we're going to graduate and
build this same project but in react
okay and this will allow us to build out
a backend more easily which is why I'm
choosing the react library to do this
and I'm going to take this project a
step further by not only just storing
the prompts on the left in the history
if we click on them it will bring back
the whole history of that chat and allow
us to add more to it so as you can see
here I am switching from each one I can
also add more text and switch back and
so on and that will be in there as well
as create a new chat if I wish okay so
that's what we're going to be doing of
course I could have also built a project
that has a JavaScript front and a no.js
backend but you know you can't do
everything so these are the two
directions I've chosen to take this
project in for the course
okay so what are we waiting for one last
thing I'm going to say is that the react
project does not use the open AI node.js
Library which does exist because I
wanted to take the exact same JavaScript
project and recreate it in react however
we will be looking at the node.js
library later on in this course when we
build out an AI image generator
foreign
hey everyone it's so great to have you
here and I'm going to be showing you the
easiest way to make a chat the GPC clone
using JavaScript okay so JavaScript HTML
and CSS this is a great project for
those wanting to learn how to use API
specifically the chat GPT API in a
single JavaScript project now this is
just for demo purposes okay we do not
want to go and publish this code onto
GitHub or deploy it because as we know
right in a simple JavaScript Project
without a backend or anything like that
you can't hide your API key so you don't
want anyone taking this API key because
if they do they can rack up loads and
loads of money on your account if you
have a credit card or anything like that
associated with it so this is just for
demo purposes if you want to know how to
build a chat GPD clone with a backhand
then I'm going to be releasing the same
video but building this in react with a
node.js backend okay we can of course
also have a JavaScript front and a
node.js backend but I think the reactor
will be way more fun to build so what
are we waiting for by the end you will
have this chat GPT clone which we will
be able to build using JavaScript HTML
and CSS and then we'll be able to ask
your questions as well as other history
of all the things we all said before
so let's do it
okay so first off we're just gonna start
a new project I'm in webstorm so I'm
simply going to select new projects and
I'm going to select an empty project so
it's being saved in my webstorm projects
directory or folder on my computer and
I'm just going to call it JavaScript
chat GPT
Club and I'm going to create so that's
going to spin it up for me and now I'm
just going to add some files I'm going
to create a new file it's an HTML file
let's call it index.html you don't
really need to put that HTML extension
in webstorm I'm doing it here for those
who are not using webstorm and then I
have this boilerplate code setup so if
you don't have this boilerplate code set
up please copy it here and I'm just
going to do JavaScript chat GPT
clone just like that and of course we
also need to create some more files so
I'm going to create a Javascript file
called object s
and then also a style sheet so I'm going
to create a new style sheet let's call
it Styles because it holds all our
styles.css
so there we go that is what my project
looks like at the moment I'm just gonna
make that smaller so what do we need to
put in here well first off I'm going to
create two sections one for the sidebar
and one for the main bit this is
actually not going to take much CSS and
HTML all so I'm just going to create a
section
there's my one section I'm going to give
it the class name of side
okay and another section this one's
going to be the main sections I'm just
going to give it a class of main to
differentiate the two sections we can
pick them out by their Style
okay so what's gonna go in our sidebar
first well in my sidebar I'm actually
going to have a button that says new
chat and it's going to clear our input
okay our search input after that I'm
also going to have a div and this is
going to hold my history okay so all the
previous uh commands that we wrote and
I'm just going to style it up a bit so
I'm going to give it a class of History
like so you don't have to use the same
style names but you know with the sake
of the tutorial maybe copy along and you
can change them later
next I'm going to create a div and this
is going to hold my nav items so I'm
going to go to the class of nav and then
for now I'm just going to have a p
element that says made by Anya you can
of course add as many elements in here
as you want you can put in links and so
on but I'm just gonna have this
and now in my main section
I'm gonna have an H1 element that says
Anya
GPT because that's what I'm calling my
clone then under here I'm going to have
a p element that is just gonna show the
output of my search so I'm going to give
this the ID of output so we can pick it
out just like so so that's one tag and
another tag
and after that I'm going to have a div
and this div is going to hold a few
things it's going to hold the input and
then a little button to submit our query
right so I'm going to give this the
class of bottom
section so we can pick it out and in
here I'm going to have a div and this is
actually going to hold my input and my
submit icon essentially so let's also
give this the class of inputs
container and then in here I'm just
going to put in an input element it's a
self-closing element and a div and this
div is going to have the ID of submit so
just like that now under so this is a
child of the main section this is a
child this whole thing is a child I'm
gonna also put a p element
uh and this is just gonna be some sub
info so let's give it a close-up info so
we can make the text smaller by picking
out this element and then I'm just going
to put chat gpg this is just from the
website itself March 14 version
in fact I'm just going to paste it so we
don't have to write all out but of
course you can pause here if you want to
have this full text right here so that
is what that text is going to say
okay so actually now we are done with
the HTML part please post here uh to
have a look at it or slow it down but
essentially that's it maybe if I zoom
out for some of you you can see
everything that is everything okay
with the correct formatting
wonderful
so at the moment if we open this up in
webstorm I can just click here
and that will bring everything up and if
I inspect the page you will see that
section that we made so there's our
section there's the other section with
all this stuff inside of it okay so now
let's get to signing up the first thing
I'm going to do is make sure the
sidebars on the left and the main
section is on the right and for that we
need to link up our style sheet and I'm
going to link up the Javascript file
while we're at it for those of you who
aren't using webstorm you can view this
by getting an indexation log page
copying the path copying the absolute
path
and just pacing in here like so it's the
same thing
great so let's carry on so let's link up
our style sheet first I'm just going to
go link and I'm going to use Rel I'm
just going to minimize this
style sheet just like so and then href
and I'm going to
link this
to the star CSS file which is in the
same place as this file so we don't need
to go into any folders or anything like
that we just get the file name and like
I said let's also do the script tag at
the bottom to link up our JavaScript
so make sure it's at the end so after
all these other elements have been read
then we want to
read this script
and there we go
so great let's get up our Starship
so first off I'm gonna get the whole
body so the thing that everything is in
and I'm just going to get rid of the
default styling by adding margin and
padding zero just like so next I'm also
going to give it a background color now
this background color I actually picked
out from the website itself so there we
go that is it that's our background
color and now so at the moment it will
look like this but these two are still
kind of on top of each other I'm also
going to change the font in the whole
project so by adding
this star like so that means everything
everything my whole entire project is
gonna have the font color of white which
is Hash FFF okay you could do three F's
but you know this is a shorthand for six
s
so that's what I have done
so now the text will be white and to
make this section to the sidebar section
and the main section of your left and
right of each other we're going to use
display flux so all I'm going to do is
on the parent of both of those which is
the body I'm gonna just write display
flex and save this file and there we go
so now the sidebar is there and the main
section is that wonderful we still have
a bunch more stuff to do so let's carry
on
I'm actually going to import a font
while we're here that font is open Sans
and for that we're going to go here and
then we're going to go to Google fonts
in Google fonts I'm going to pick out
the open Sans font so all I'm going to
do is search open Sans click on it and
then I'm going to select a few we can
select as many as we want so let's go
ahead I'm going to select maybe all of
these so basically just not the italic
ones so that we have them to our
dispersal in the project I'm going to
choose to import them via the style
sheet so I'm just going to take this
code in between these two style tags
and then in my project I'm just going to
paste it in like so okay so there we go
there's the uh semicolon at the end and
all the weights to my disposal and once
that is done that means I can now use
the font family open Sans so font family
open Sans and then as a backup I'm going
to have Sans sir so if you didn't know
which code to use you can actually get
it from here here's the CSS rule to
apply that family and you just get that
one great and that's it so that just
means that that font will now be applied
to my project
let's carry on
so now that we have done that I'm also
going to pick out any H1 elements in my
project and assign them a different font
size because I don't like the default
one so I'm just going to go font size 33
pixels and a font weight so we just
import a loads of font weights I want to
go with 600 and I'm also going to pad it
out so I'm going to use the padding
property and I'm going to say 200 pixels
from the top and bottom and zero from
the left and right so that's a shorthand
okay this is top bottom
and it's the same as me writing this but
because there's repetition I can remove
it and that will now be applied to the
top and bottom and this to the left and
right so if we look at it now
that's what it would look like there's
my H1 element
great
now let's actually pick out the sidebar
so I'm picking on Ellen or the class of
sidebar that dot means class as you can
see here we're looking here going
ah here's an element with a class a
sidebar so let's pick out the whole
thing
so that's what I have done now I'm going
to give this a different background
color again I have picked this out from
the project
so from the actual website itself and
I'm going to say the width of this is
going to be 244 pixels
the height is going to be 100 of a
viewport height so VH so whatever the
browser size is the height I'm getting
it and I'm also going to make sure that
everything inside is going to be sat on
top of each other with equal spacing so
I'm going to use display Flex for that
so I'm initializing flexbox so then I
can use flex
Direction okay without this this will
not work and I'm going to make sure that
everything in the sidebar is a column so
like stacked over each other so that's
what I would use
so if I look at this now you will see
okay there's a button there's basically
everything in the sidebar so this this
this it starts on top of each other but
what if I want them to appear equally
spaced right so the number is all the
way at the bottom this is kind of in the
middle space so equally between the
button and the nav bar well I can use
justify content space
between
so now if I refresh this there's our P
element
let's see let's maybe go in here so
there's our div with the nav Clause
that's our Dev with the class of history
and there's our button so the spacing
between all three is equal and no matter
if I change this that space will always
be equal no matter how big the browser
is
so I like that
let's Carry On Let's also now maybe
style the main section so the other
section once again I'm going to use
display flex and I'm going to use flex
Direction column just to make sure
they're all stacked over each other but
this time I want to align items to the
center so I'm actually aligning them
from left to right because we've changed
axis of display Flex if none of this
makes sense please do check out my full
stack developer course where I go into
this in a lot more detail as flexbox can
be quite confusing
so that just means I've centered
everything from right to left by using a
line item Center and we're doing it from
this axis as we've swapped the axis by
actually making them a column so
whatever direction we're going in if
it's a column
align items will be on the opposite axis
great
so this is looking good so far let's
carry it on I'm also going to use text
align Center to make sure that the text
is in the center
which it is but now in the bottom part
is as well because at the moment it's
being aligned to the left
and once again I'm going to use justify
content space between just to make sure
that they are also spread out equally no
matter how I make the browser that will
always be at the bottom and this will be
pushed to the top so I'm spacing
everything out equally on this axis
great
so I'm happy with
that the other thing we need to do is
assign this a height so I'm going to go
with height 100 of the viewport height
so now
that text will always be stuck to the
bottom because we're taking the browser
height into consideration
next let's style up this text so it's a
bit smaller and more transparent so we
gave this the class of info so let's
pick out this whole element the hobby
element by the class name so I'm just
going to grab the class name of info and
I'm going to make the color of this a
transparent so I'm going to use rgba I'm
going to go with white
and then I'm going to put 0.5
opacity so to make it consistent you
might want to consider changing these to
be rgb2 just so that we don't have hex
colors and RGB colors in the same
project so I might leave that as
something I will do at the end
next I'm just going to also change the
font size to be 11 pixels because I want
it to be a bit smaller and I'm also
going to Pat it out I'm going to do 10
pixels packaging all around
so now my text will look like that that
is much more like the website wonderful
let's
carry on
I think Nexus also maybe uh style what
should we style next I think let's style
the input itself so this thing right
here so I'm just going to grab the input
element
I'm gonna get rid of its default border
so I'm going to go with those none and
let's go with background color again I
think let's just use this color so like
a transparent white I'm going to make
sure that the width is 100 of the pound
container the font size is going to be
20 pixels
let's Pat it out I'm going to pan out 12
pixels from the top and bottom and 15
pixels from the left and right and just
round off the edges slightly so I'm
going to do gluta radius
5 pixels
and now I'm gonna do border radius five
pixels just to round up the edges oops
don't forget to have that syntax right
there
okay and finally I'm just going to add a
box Shadow because who doesn't love a
box shadow
and this time the color I'm going to go
with is RGB black so that's black I want
to make it transparent so I'm going to
go 0.05 and add a here to give it
opacity I'm gonna go zero pixels x-axis
54 pixels y-axis 55 pixels blur uh we
don't need pixels here if it's zero so
we're just going to get rid of that and
we're going to Overlay it with another
color so actually I'm just gonna maybe
copy this
as we're gonna have the same color
however this time I'm gonna go minus 12
pixels here and then 30 pixels blur and
then again the same thing so I'm going
to paste again and this time I have zero
four
six so I'm just overlaying different box
Shadows to get a desired effect that I
want and zero
12.
and maybe let's have one more so
0.09 this time and this time minus three
pixels y-axis 5 pixels blur so that is
my whole box Shadow and effect will be
this
and if I type in here that will happen
we can get rid of this blue line in fact
I'm gonna do that because I really don't
like it so I'm gonna say that when the
input
is focused
we're gonna do outline none
so now if we look in here I have gotten
rid of that so much better
great now this input is stretched out
100 of its parents
which is the input container or the
input container I also want to be
stretched I want to make it bigger
so let's grab the input container so the
element by the class name input
container and I'm also going to make
that 100
width of its parent I'm also actually
going to assign a Max width so it's
going to try to be 100 but then it's
going to stop at 650 pixels okay great
this also means that the parent of the
input container needs to have some sort
of width assigned to it
in fact we can go and actually get main
a width so let's go make sure that the
main element is a hundred percent and
now the child of Maine is bottom section
so if this is 100 next I'm going to get
the bottom section
and also make sure that width is 100
percent
great and now let's Center everything so
main already has display Flex on it so
we're gonna have to get the bottom
section and make sure that everything in
the bottom section is also aligned in
the center so let's use display Flex
so I'm going to do display Flex
Flex Direction column
justify content Center
align items Center again if flexbox is
so when you haven't covered before
please consider checking out my full
stack developer course where we go into
this in a lot more detail so great so
now everything in the bottom section is
also centered how good is that and if we
kind of make this as big or small as we
want it will always be in the center
wonderful
so let's carry on just a few more
styling things to do before we can
continue
so
next I'm just going to style up the
input container and submit button so for
this I'm going to actually go in here
and put in a text symbol so it's this
little arrow right here that I've taken
off the internet that's a text symbol if
you want to get your own I mean I'm just
going to Google it so you can see you
can get it from here
so just copy that that is the URL that
you would need so now if I refresh this
there's a little text symbol wherever I
want it here right I want it to appear
on the actual input itself which is why
I put them both in an input container so
that I can position them thanks to
position relative and absolute so let's
give the input a position relative
relative to the whole page so we can use
position absolute on these two things to
position them based on the parent so
let's do it again this is something that
you can learn in my course
so input container
let's give it a position of relative so
that we can give the children a position
absolute to position them and I'm gonna
get the input container or the element
by the class of input container and say
that if an element with the ID of submit
lives inside of it that is the Syntax
for doing so
I'm going to give it a position of
absolute
okay
so now if I refresh this that shows up
here and now I'm going to position it in
relation to the input container so I'm
just going to go
right zero so it should appear on the
right zero
so if I save that
there we go and I'm going to move up
from the bottom 15 pixels okay so the
from the bottom of the parent element so
let's go bottom
15 pixels
so now that should appear right there
and again it will move based on the
input container so the parent the other
thing I want to do is change the cursor
so that it's obvious I can click on it
so I'm just going to add cursor
pointer
just like so and save that and now my
casa will change so that will appear
that I can click on this
great we are so nearly done I'm just
going to style these things a little bit
more so the button the history and the
nav
container so let's do it
so the button itself I'm just going to
give it a border of solid 0.5 pixels and
it will transparent white so we know
that's two by five two five five two
five five zero point five I'm going to
go with a piece of D and then the
background
color
let's go a transparent
border radius five pixels padding 10
pixels and margin 10 pixels to space it
out from everything else
so with that styling this is what my
bottom run out looked like that is much
more like the actual website and the nav
well I just want to line above it really
and to space it out a bit so I'm going
to get the element that has a class name
of nav we could have maybe used the nav
element but you know that is up to you
okay maybe let's just switch it out
semantically that would probably make
more sense so if we go ahead and get rid
of this whole class
and just use enough element instead that
is also an option okay and that just
means I can pick up the whole nav
element and I'm going to give it a
broader
top
of solid 0.5 pixels in fact it's going
to be the same color as this so let's
pick that out
oops just make sure that's a 0.5
so now that will look like this I just
added a line and I'm just going to space
it out so once again let's just add the
same padding and margin that we did for
the button and finally let's grab the
element that has the class name of
History also give it the same padding
and margin and I'm also going to use
display Flags to make sure that anything
I put into it because I'm going to be
putting stuff into it with JavaScript
it's going to be stacked on top of each
other so I'm going to use flex Direction
column and I'm also going to make sure
that it takes up 100 of the height that
it can
great
next I know that I'm going to be putting
P elements into this history so we're
going to be using JavaScript essentially
put elements in here we're going to be
injecting elements with JavaScript and
those are going to be P elements so I'm
going to say that any P element that I
put that lives inside an element with
the class of History so that is the
Syntax for doing so I'm just going to
make sure that you can point on it so
I'm going to put Casa pointer and there
we go
so our CSS is now done now time for the
part that I'm sure you've all been
waiting for and that's using the chat
GPT API
so let's do it
so I'm just gonna head over to
openai.com of course you have to sign up
this will be a free service I believe up
to a certain amount and
I'll just opened this up a new browser
so we can differentiate
so here is the URL that you need to be
in as you can see I am logged in is
platform.openai.com
Introduction and if you go to API
reference
all you're going to need to do is get
your open API key so under
authentication if you actually visit
your API Keys here you can create a new
key so this is one I made before let's
go ahead and create a new one so this is
the thing that you need to keep safe
okay because if you attach a credit card
to this someone will be able to take it
and rack up loads of money on your
credit card or even if you don't maybe
someone will use it and then you won't
be able to use any free Generations
anymore
so keep this safe and of course we are
putting in this in our project but
please don't upload this onto GitHub or
share it with anyone this is just for
demo purposes if you want to learn how
to actually deploy this app and keep
your API Keys safe then we'll do that in
the next video where I show you how to
make the same thing but in react by
building out a node.js pack
okay again as I said you can build out a
front end in JavaScript and use a
node.js backend too so both options are
viable
okay so let's carry on
so once we have that API key well we're
actually going to go back to API
references and we're going to look at
completions so click on completions
because this is the URL that we're going
to have to post to
so that's what we're going to do along
with passing or along our open API key
thanks to an authorization header and
then as well as the text or the prompt
that we want to pass on to the open AI
API
so let's do it I'm going to show you how
so in your app.js file I'm going to save
this as API key I will be disabling this
so don't try to use it because it won't
work I'm just showing you this for now
I'm just going to put in this texture so
it's super obvious to everyone not to
deploy it or upload it onto GitHub next
I'm going to write a function this is
going to be an async function
okay so you can write it like this if
you want
or you can use const it's totally up to
you you can make it a function
declaration or just a functional
expression that choice is yours and I'm
going to use get message I'm going to
call it get message because that's
essentially what we are doing
and I'm going to use try and catch to
try do something and catch any errors so
this is the
Syntax for this if you haven't seen it
before this is how we can make a calls
now I'm gonna hook this up to the submit
button so if we click on this div with
the idea of submit I essentially want to
make that call so let's pick it out so
all I'm going to do is go const submit
button so we're saving it as submit
button so you can use it in our
Javascript file I'm going to look in my
document look at my whole document for
an element so I'm going to use Query
selector I'm going to look for something
by the ID of submits that's what this
will do oh look at my whole document and
look for an element that has the ID of
submit so we can use it in our
Javascript file
so I'm going to get that submit button
I'm going to add an event listener and
say that if I click on it then I'm going
to call the function the async function
get message okay so that's what that
will do so for now if I just console log
clicked
and then let's go back to this and click
on this little thing and check our
console it says clicked if I click it
again two three four you'll see how many
times we are clicking it so that's all I
have done so far now let's get to
actually passing stuff on to the API
so what I'm going to do is well we're
going to use the fetch keyword right so
I'm going to use a weight fetch it's an
async method which is why this is an
async function and we're going to await
for its responses we're going to await
it and await an async keywords live
together if I use a weight that means
that that function needs to be an async
function
so again check out my course if this
doesn't make any sense
now I'm going to fetch well this is what
I want to fetch I want to make a post
request of this URL so let's grab this
URL because we want to create
completions we don't want to you know
create images or anything like that even
though we can but not for this project
that's not what we're going to do so
this is the URL that we're going to do
is go into the chat and the completions
okay so make sure to have that one right
there chat chat completions this is the
full URL and it's a post request and
this we're going to use this okay in
order to uh create our own post request
so we're going to have the content type
we're gonna have the authorization the
model and the messages so let's go ahead
and do it let's create that data that
information and I'm going to Define it
under options
so let's define our options const
options and we're just going to
literally be taking that information
so what I'm going to do is pass the
method we know it's a
post method
as we just saw that making sure that is
like this
and we're also going to pass through the
headers which we also just saw the
headers are going to be
authorization so let's grab that
put it in here
and then we're going to do back six so
we can write code in here because we're
going to use our API token so dollar
curly braces is how you'll put in code
and I'm just going to pass through this
API key so that's all I'm doing
next what else do we need we need to
pass through the content type
so content type and that is going to be
once again I'm just going to paste it
because I'm lazy application Json so
that is how you would read what you are
seeing here in order to create your own
uh
API call in your code
we're also going to have to pass through
some more information so essentially
what model we want to use and the
message we want to send over
so I can just copy this essentially
maybe let's do that
and let's do a comma here and do body
and then oops we don't need two of these
so body and then just paste it like so
so great we have the model we're going
to use GPT 3.5 turbo silhouetting gpg4
or access to it we're going to have the
messages in fact we don't need these we
can actually get rid of that
just like that same four
that uh same for the Raw
and same for the content the content
though we can pass through the string of
hello or we can pass whatever we put in
our input so we will do that and we can
also put the maximum number of token
words the bot should return if we want
uh or we don't have to so you can put
Max token
um
if you wish
but I think let's just leave it actually
maybe let's do it just so you know how
to do it if you want to limit the tokens
so max
tokens
I'm gonna go with 100. okay and I think
we just need to pass this through
Jason's stringify just to make sure it's
Json so I'm going to pass through that
whole object like so wonderful so that
is looking good
okay so we're making the API call we're
passing through the options so all the
information it needs which is all of
this now let's get the data so we're
going to use a weight I'm going to await
the responses Json so just like so and
then once we have that let's save it as
the const data
okay so essentially it's doing the Fetch
and then we're waiting for the response
so let's save this under response
and then when we get the response we're
going to get the Json from it but uh oh
this is actually an async method which
you might not know but it is which is
why we need to await it again and once
we have it we can save it under data and
once we have data I'm just going to
console log out data for you great
uh and now let's catch any errors I'm
just going to pass through error
and I'm just going to console error the
error
okay let's test it out well we can't
just do hello so that just means that
let's refresh if I click on this it will
make the call and we're just waiting for
it and amazing we've just passed you
hello and then this whole object comes
back we're going to go into the object
get the choices go into the first item
in the array and get the message so the
message is hello there how may I assist
you so that's essentially what we want
to show in the
uh in the browser right so instead of
just console logging out the data
what I'm gonna do is pick out
the output element so this P element I
right here by its ID
so let's look in the whole document
again document
query selector this time I'm going to
look for the ID of output
let's save it as output
elements
so I'm just going to get that output
element
and I'm going to use
text content
to get the data however go into the
object get the choices as I said go into
the first item of that array get the
message
so let's have a look here again so again
this is data right that's what we saved
as data we then go into choices get the
first item of the array as an array so
it goes zero and get the message dot
content
so we're just going to get that first uh
item back each time
so great let's check it out I'm gonna
try once more so obviously this is just
sending the string hello and then we
should see hello there how amazes you
today so this is looking good of course
we want to send our own messages not
just hello right
so let's carry on
one thing I also want to do is just save
it as the history so if this exists
right because we don't want to save
empty strings we just want to make sure
that if something exists then what I'm
going to do is create a p element
document create element and I'm going to
create a p element so a paragraph
element or maybe let's make it
now let's make a p element that is fine
uh and that P element
I'm going to get the text content and
I'm just going to get whatever we
actually wrote in the input so actually
maybe we should do the input first I'm
just going to comment this out for now
I'm going to pick out this input
so document query selector input we only
have one so it's fine for me just to
pick up the whole input
and let's save it as input element
and instead of passing through hello I'm
going to get input element value so
whatever value that input has will be
passed through and also I also want to
pass it through to history so if a
message comes back to us and it's
successful I want to get the input
elements
value and just essentially add that text
to the P element we just created however
other members P elements just floating
around we can't see it I need to append
it to the history element so let's pick
out
the element by the class of History
document query selector
class of History so dot is class and
let's say this as history
element
and I'm gonna get the history element
and I'm going to use a method called
append to put in that P element so once
again if text comes back to us from the
API then we create a p element we add
some text to it which is essentially
whatever we put in the input and then we
get it and we put it into the history
element
so that's what I have done for now
so if we have a look at this let's put
in something uh what can I ask it what
day is it
question mark and send this
we wait
okay oh it does not have I would have
thought it would have told me what day
it is but it has not and we get that in
the history okay so if we look in here
the his the div with the class of
History which before had nothing in it
now has a p element with the text that
we wrote in here right so that is pretty
cool and if we of course add more that
will be appended to that as well
so this is all looking wonderful so far
we have done a lot with uh we have a few
more things to do I if I will click on
this I want to bring back the prompt and
if I click on here I want to clear this
input so let's do that next
let's pick out the button so document
query selector
button there's only one so this should
be fine what should we call this I think
we should
just call it button element as there is
only one in this project
so I'm going to grab the button element
let's just do so down here and I'm going
to add event listener and if I click on
it I want to clear the input so let's
write a function called
clear
input
let's do so maybe up here function clear
and I'm just going to grab the input
element get its value and just override
it with an empty string so that should
now work
one last thing I'm going to do is also
add an event listener
foreign
so if we click on anything in here it
brings it essentially gets that text and
puts it back in here so let's do it I
think as soon as we create the P element
right and we put in the text I'm also
gonna add an event listener to it that
says if we click on it all I want to do
I'm going to make this a callback so
just we can we so that we can
essentially pass stuff through into a
function that I'm going to call change
input
so into here I am well let's actually
maybe just pass through
the P elements text content as that's
what we're going to want to change it to
and let's define our function so let's
define up here function change input and
then we're going to pass through a value
that value is essentially what we want
to change the input to uh and what I'm
going to do is use document queries
selector
to look for the element of input again
so whatever the freshest value of it is
so if I'm just going to save it as input
element for now
and get that input element
value and just assign it the value
so there we go I think we have done it I
think we've built our own chat GPT clone
let's give it a go so let's ask it
something else
how are you today
send and wait for that to come back
okay so there we go we are getting some
text to come back to us and that gets
saved up here and then if I go
what can I ask it now
what is four plus two
and send that over
the answer is six and then if I click on
here that will get back the same
question so I don't have to type it out
again as you will see that's updating
and if I click on here that will or
should clear the input why is that not
working let's inspect here
let's have a look in here
ah we've misspelled value while we are
here I'm just going to change the
opacity of the input to be much more
like the actual thing and I should also
check that the input value exists and if
the input value exists and the message
that contacts exists then I only wanted
to put it in the chat history so there
we go let's try that again let's refresh
what is six plus two
and that should give me the response
how old are you question mark
and that should ask it the question and
then I can bring back the previous input
as well as clear this so we can't start
again
great so I hope you've learned something
new I hope you've learned how to use the
chat
GPT API or in other words the open AI
API that powers chat GPT
as a beginner it could be quite
frustrating when you want to use this
but you haven't learned react yet so
that is how you would do it for your own
personal projects if you want to level
up check out my video on how we build
the same thing but in react next
hey everyone and welcome to this video
which we're going to learn how to use
the open AI API or in other words the
thing that powers chat GPT to build our
own chat GPT clone and we're going to be
doing this in react for the front end
with a node.js packet so that's what
we're going to be doing today the final
product will look like this and it'll
allow us to write text prompts and once
we do that we'll start a new chat
automatically and then we can carry on
having a chat with the AI now if we want
to create a new chat all we do is click
on the button and that will generate a
new job for us and automatically that
past tax product will be saved to the
history and the best part about it is
that we can go back to the previous chat
and add to again go to the next one add
to that and that will be tracked
accordingly and of course we can create
new chats as well so that is a cool
feature that I'm going to show you how
to do and we're going to be saving that
to six of course we will also be keeping
our API Keys safe and we're going to try
do it with not using all our free tokens
okay so I am super excited about this
what are we waiting for let's get to it
okay so first off I'm just going to
create a new project I'm using webstorms
so all I have to do is click here and I
can select react and then I can call
this whatever I want so I'm going to
call this react chat GPT clone okay and
that will get made in my web store
projects and it's going to use this
command so npx and then the string
create react up as one so that is
separated by a space here and I'm just
going to click create
now for those of you who aren't using
webstorm or you would do is use your
terminal
so here is my terminal I'm just going to
make it bigger and then you can
gravitate wherever you want so I'm going
to go into webstorm projects and then
you would use npx create react app and
then whatever you want to call your
project so react chat GPT clone and hit
enter okay so that is what you would do
of course I'm not going to do it this
way because I'm using website which has
done all that for me so this is
essentially spinning up all the files
and configuration that I need for this
project
so we're just going to wait for that to
do its thing
so when that is ready it should say
happy hacking
and there we go happy hacking as I will
see all the folders and correct files
are already in there for me
so let's just clean this up a little bit
we're not going to write any tests so
I'm just going to delete these two
I'm gonna delete that we also don't need
a logo so let's go ahead and delete the
logo I'm also going to delete the app
test file because we're not writing any
tests as well as the CSS file because
I'm just gonna pull my CSS in one file
because it's a small project
so that's it so at the moment you should
just have these three files in the
source directory the app.js file looks
like this and I'm just gonna delete
everything
in here so we can start fresh that is
what it should look like I'm also going
to change this to a functional I
expression just because that is my
preference and we don't need these two
inputs so this is what your app.js file
should look like your CSS file should
just be empty so we can start fresh and
your index.js well we're not wearing any
tests so let's delete that we don't need
this and then delete the semicolons
again that is a personal preference and
we are ready to roll
so that is my index.js file that is my
index CSS file and that's my app.js file
and that's all that we should have in
here
great
so again like I said this is a really
small project so we're actually not
going to have any components or anything
like that because this is about learning
how to use the open AI API so I'm just
going to start building up my app
so I'm going to start up by having two
sections so one section that's going to
be for the sidebar and one section is
going to be for the I guess main part of
the app so let's give this the class
name of
side well and this the class name of
main so we can differentiate between the
two
main so what do we want to go in our
sidebar well I want to have a button uh
this is going to create a new chat and
I'm going to just put a little plus text
icon here
if you want to know where I got the text
icon from
I'm just going to search for it you can
simply just get it by searching for it
so if you visit this URL you'll be able
to get that plus sign as well
so I believe so anyway let's just find
yeah so there it is
great so that is my text icon
next up after the button I'm gonna
actually have an ordered list and this
is going to be for the history of all
our previous prompts so I'm just going
to pick it out by the class name of
history as well just to kind of make
things more readable and in here we're
actually going to map out onto list
items the first prompt that we wrote for
the chat the fast text prompt so we'll
leave that for now
and lastly I'm going to have a NAB
element and in here I'm just going to
have the P element of made by Anya so
that is my whole section my first
section it's got three children which I
want to space out evenly so I'm going to
use justify content space between to
space them out evenly so shall we do
that
yeah let's do it okay so let's get my
index CSS uh file up I'm going to say
that everything so star means everything
everything in this uh I guess project is
going to have the font color of white
and the font family of open sand so open
Sans is something that I'm going to get
from Google fonts so please go ahead and
just get it as well so just go to Google
fonts and then all you're going to do is
search for open Sans
there it is and then I'm going to select
the appropriate ones I'm going to
actually select all the weights so that
we have
all of them to our disposal so I think
that's it I'm not getting the italic
ones so if you click here
we can then import them you can do
import them into the HTML or the CSS I'm
going to import them into the CSS I'm
going to grab that and I'm just what I'm
going to do is just paste it making sure
that that's semicolons at the end and
you can see all the font weights that we
have to ask disposal
so now if I want to use this use the
rule that I need to use we can have
anything as a backup I'm happy having
Sun serve as a backup as they have kind
of given us so there we go
so yeah everything in here is going to
have essentially white text that is open
sand and if open Sound doesn't work it
will revert to sunserve as the backup
next I'm going to grab the whole body
and I'm just going to get rid of any
default margin and padding so margin
and padding I'm just going to set a zero
to get rid of any weird funky white
borders that we may have
and now let's make this bigger I'm going
to grab so the wrapping element so the
element or the class name of app
so let's grab it by the class name and
I'm just going to give the whole app a
background color so the background color
I have picks out already directly from
chat GPT and it is this three four three
five four one
okay and I'm just going to make sure
that the Side Bar
so let's saw the sidebar but also main
let's give them both some styling first
to the sidebar and on the background
color of this to be darker again I have
picked this out as 202 one two three
and I'm actually going to make sure that
the height is 100 of the viewport height
but the width is only 244 pixels and
it's going to be stuck at 244 pixels
okay and while we're here I'm also just
going to make sure
well let's just leave it at that for now
and the main
I'm also going to give it a height of
100 of the vehicle height but width I'm
just going to say 100 so it's going to
try to take up 100 but obviously we've
got the sidebar there at the moment
though let's go ahead and start this
project so in webstorm I can just hit
here and it will run the command npm
start so essentially look in here and
run this command but if you are not
using Web Store I'm just going to show
you how to do it you would find the
project first so webstone projects and
this is what we call this react to HB
clone you would do npm Run start and hit
enter okay because you're literally just
doing npm run and whatever we've called
this we call this start so that runs
this
so let's go ahead and undo that on
webstorm so I'm just going to go here
and it should start up my
boom
so great this is looking very cool
I'm just going to inspect it for now
so I want essentially this to be you
know just spaced out evenly right I want
it to appear this to be at the bottom
and then history which at the moment
doesn't have much starting to be in the
middle and the new chat button to be at
the top I can use so with display Flex
so let's minimize this I'm going to
minimize that too and on the sidebar I'm
going to initialize flexbox
so that was initialized so I can use it
and we now want everything to be stacked
on top of each other because if I save
this it will you know stuck next to each
other we don't want that we want it to
be over each other so Flex Direction
column
and now I'm going to do justify content
space between
so now they are spaced out and if I kind
of move this
it'll always be at the bottom the space
between all the three children
should be equal so in here the three
children there's one child as the second
child and the third child has equal
spacing between them
let's carry on maybe let's just make
this a little bit smaller
okay maybe let's start the button and
the nav first before moving on let's
just complete the side one
so there is my side bar
I'm also going to
grab the button and just give it a
border solid 0.5 pixels uh and then make
it kind of well I'm gonna do white but
then I'm going to make a 0.5 or pastes
to you so A is for a piece of t uh make
sure to spell button correctly we
shouldn't really use RGB and hex so we
can swap that out at the end
and then let's also give it a background
color of transparency we've given it a
border we've got a little background
color let's round off the edges
border radius
and let's go with five pixels
and then padding
10 pixels margin
okay
so that's what I have done so now it
looks like that very much like the real
thing now let's do the nav bar so let's
go back here and let's grab the nav
element
and all I'm going to do is give it a
border at the top so I'm going to do
border again but this time just bought a
top and literally just copy
this line really
okay but that's going to apply it just
at the top and let's also give it the
same padding so let's just copy this
just to keep it consistent
okay
so now it looks like this
wonderful this is looking great
now if I was to start adding elements
into here so into the history so say we
have a list item or
already a lot of what we do for now it's
going to look like this I don't really
want the Dots here so I'm going to show
you how to get rid of that as well as
give some padding to the whole unordered
list
so let's grab the unordered list first
okay I'm just going to grab it by the
element because we don't really have any
on other unordered lists in here right I
mean you could grab it by the history I
gave a class name to make it more
readable so maybe let's just do that
some dot history
dot is for class name as hopefully you
know and let's apply the same particle
margin for consistency I'm also just
gonna uh maybe give make sure that it
spaces out 100 percent
and now every list item that lives
inside the element with the class of
History
I'm just going to use list Style
type
none
okay and that will remove that dot okay
now I'm also going to Pat it out however
I just want to Pat it out 15 pixels from
the top and bottom and zero from the
left and right so that is a shorthand
for doing that that would apply to the
top and bottom of this to the left and
right and I'm also wanted to give it a
cursor of pointer because I'm going to
want to be able to click on these right
so I want it to be very obvious that we
can click on them by changing the
pointer like so
all right
done so we're now done with this side
bar maybe let's get rid of but let's
keep that for now
okay so let's move on to the main
section now let's do it
now my main section well I'm just going
to give this the H1 element of Anya and
gb2 like so and then I'm also going to I
guess make a feed so we're going to use
another unordered list so luckily we
gave that our class name because I am
going to use another unordered list so
let's give this the class name of
feed it's going to be for our feed and
we're going to also map out onto here
some list items which is essentially
going to be each chat
um do we want to do this
now maybe let's leave that for now so
we're going to map onto of course you
know list items but we'll leave that
let's then make a div
and let's give this the class name of
Autumn section and it's going to busy
hold everything that needs to go in the
bottom section and what goes in the
bottom section well we're going to have
an input I'm going to wrap it in an
input container so I'm going to make a
div with a class name of
input container so that we can
essentially position a little icon on
top of the input so let's put in our
input
there we go and then I'm also going to
add a div and give this the ID of submit
okay
so that is it and again I'm just going
to use some text symbol if you want to
Google it that is it and you can get it
from Unicode characters so that is the
URL to do it
great
so now let's go back here Okay so we've
got our input container and under the
input container so make sure it's after
this closing tag that's linked to here
I'm going to put a p element
let's give this the class name of info
as I want to style this up a little bit
smaller than a normal P element and it's
just going to have the text that I've
stolen from the chat GPT website
okay
wonderful
so we've now finished with all of this
at the moment uh you know it's under
here because we have our sidebar here
and then our main is under here we need
to use these two to appear next to each
other so the parent of the sidebar and
the main element is the devil class name
of app
so let's go back into here
and just right here I'm going to use
display
flex and that should make both of these
appear next to each other like so
great let's style up the main element a
bit more next
so the main element well I want
everything I guess to kind of be in the
center but also uh with space between
so once again I'm going to initialize
flexbox
so display
flex and once that is done of course
everything will appear from left to
right we want to appear from top to
bottom so what I can do is use flex
Direction column
and now I'm just going to justify
content space between
okay so it looks like that and now let's
Center the text as well as everything
else actually so we're going to use
align item Center which again is part of
flexbox you can't use a line items
Center and you can't use this in fact
you can't use any of these three without
initializing flexbox so just keep that
in mind and now let's also Center the
text so once again I'm going to do text
align this time Center and I believe
that's all we need to do so that is what
it looks like
next I am just going to make this
smaller and more transparent so the P
element with the class name of info
so what I'm going to do is grab the
class name of info and the color of this
text is well it's not going to be white
I'll just override that so I'm going to
do RGB a two five five two five five two
five five zero point five Oak piece of T
is what I'm going to give it
next I'm just going to send the font
size
one size 11 pixels and Pat it out just a
little bit though by 10 pixels so at the
moment it will look like this okay just
much more I guess realistic let's tackle
the input next
so the input well of course the input
and the uh icon are children of the
input container and we want to do some
positioning which is why we're going to
use position relative on this and then
position this based on the parent by
giving it position absolute and then
some values for top and left I believe
let's have a look uh okay so let's grab
the input container actually the other
side
so top right or bottom right top or
bottom it's up to us
so let's yes grab the input container
like I said we need to give a position
of relative relative to everything else
so essentially not much will change for
that but we need to do it in order to
position the child
and one other thing that the input
container is in is the bottom section
which we're going to have to assign a
width to so the bottom section let's
just say we want this style width of a
hundred percent just like so
there we go
I'm also going to use display Flex on it
and make sure that everything's stacked
on top of each other so I'm going to use
black selection column and then let's
also Center everything so justify
content to Center and align items Center
so everything's going to be centered
from uh top to bottom and then left and
right
so that should be
good so yes it is and now let's so here
is D I'm just going to show you exactly
how big that bottom section is it
stretches
and then if we go into the bottom
section I need the input container to
stretch too so the input container
let's also give it a width of 100
but then also stop it so cap it if it
gets to
650 pixels anyway
okay
great so again that won't look like much
because now we need to stretch the input
that lives inside of it so now let's
grab the actual input itself
um and the width is going to be 100 now
I'm also going to get rid of the border
of this
let's give it a background color which
is going to be rgbase it's going to be
white and it's going to be super okay so
0.05 I'm gonna do
and let's also give it a padding at the
top of 12 pixels and 15 pixels from the
left and right so this is applied to the
top and bottom and this to the left and
right and round it off so I'm going to
do border radius 5 pixels
okay so one other thing that I should
probably do
is
well let's have a look at what this
looks like at the moment so actually
this looks good I'm happy with that I
don't really want uh any focus on this
so that blue line so what I'm also going
to do is grab the inputs
focus and I'm just going to do outline
now okay so that will get rid of that
and one last thing I'm just also going
to add some box Shadow I'm essentially
going to Overlay lots of box Shadows on
top of each other the first color is
going to be black
with 0.05 opacity 0x axis 54 pixels
y-axis 55 pixels blur and then overlay
with another one so in fact I'm just
going to copy this because I think we're
going to keep the color the same but
just change uh the X and Y and blurs so
I'll make this minus 12 and change this
to 30.
to again
[Music]
and this time it's zero let's put four
pixels and six pixels
and then again
of 0 12 3 pixels and a final one
of zero
minus three and five
so there we go that's a lot
and we just need to change all of these
to the commas instead because it's just
one long box shadow
so the desired effect is now there let's
position this next
so
this time what I'm going to do is grab
the submit
okay so they did with the ID of submit
and I'm going to use position
absolute so at the moment that will
appear here but I wanted to appear here
and I wanted to position it from the
parent from the bottom 15 and from the
right zero
so let's go out and do that bottom 15
pixels and write zero and I'm also going
to change the cursor so like we did
before to be pointer so that we know
that we can click on this and the end
result is that you can probably move it
a little bit down that does seem kind of
high up or maybe let's make the font
size bigger for here maybe let's do that
so again on the input I'm just going to
change the font
size to be 20 pixels if we write in the
input
and great that is so much better I think
we're now ready to actually cook this up
a little bit to the API and for this
we're going to build a Bakken so let's
do it
so back in here what I'm going to do is
on the same level as the package Json
I'm just going to create a new file so
let's go ahead and add a new file I'm
going to call it index
or let's call it server.js you can call
it whatever you want really so that is
now our server so that's our backend
okay and we're gonna have to install a
few things uh so let's go ahead and do
that first
so I'm going to install a package called
cause Express
know them on
and I think that's it if you want a bit
more information as to what these are
please do check out my podcast developer
course where I go into this in a bunch
more detail okay or you can do your own
research just research those packages
otherwise let's carry on so you will see
those packages having us all here along
with their version so if something isn't
working make sure to move up back to
these versions and install that version
okay if you are watching this in the
future
so now that we've done that let's write
a script to start our back end I'm going
to call it start but this time I'm going
to write back end and it's
differentiated already in the front end
for this one
front end you're going to say that
because you can read it and to start
this well we're literally going to use
the package that we just installed to
listen out for constant changes on my
back end so I'm going to do notamon and
then we're going to listen up changes on
server.js
great so now let's start our front end
again so I'm just going to stop it from
running here and do npm Run start front
end and hit enter okay so that will just
re-run that and I'm going to create
another tab so I can run my backend so
keep both of those running npm Run start
back end
and hit enter so now our backend is
running
so let's actually Define a port
before it will run on first so I'm going
to minimize that so we're done with the
package.json let's get off our server.js
file
so we're going to run our backend on
Port 8000 and let's also just go ahead
and require
those packages that we literally just
installed so we're going to use express
we're also going to use cores so require
course
to get rid of any closed messages that
we might come across and now let's
initialize it so I'm going to
essentially get Express we've got the
package we've saved and express I'm
going to release everything by doing
that and save it under app so we can use
it in this project
so now I'm also I know I'm going to be
working with Jason so I'm just going to
use um
Express Json that will allow us to work
with Json when we start sending stuff
from the front end to the back end with
our post requests and I'm also going to
do app use uh course because I know that
I'm going to run into some course error
messages so that is the setup now I'm
going to do app listen
to listen out essentially on Port
so let's actually uh just write a
message your server
is
running on ports and then whatever the
port is support 8 000 are cons is 8 000
that we're using here
okay
um we actually need to
make this a callback function because we
report as the first parameter and this
as the second parameter and then console
log this out so consult blog
top okay
great so now if we look in here it says
your server is running on 40 000 and if
I make any changes so if I just do
console.log
apply that will rerun
okay and same if I visit localhost 8 000
here
that is our port and it's running of
course we haven't written any Express
routes so that is why it says cannot get
anything while we visit the Home Route
right here but let's carry on
so I'm just going to minimize that
okay so now it's time for us to get our
API key so all I'm going to do is head
over to open Ai and I'm going to go to
developers API reference okay of course
you have to be signed in so just make
sure you are I am currently signed in
and we are going to get our API key so
all you have to do is go here view API
keys and I'm going to create a new
secret key so copy that it's really that
easy there it is if you uh got lost just
make sure to visit this URL when you are
signed in and you can create as many as
you want of course if yours gets taken
or you think it's compromise you can
delete it as well
so keep that in mind I just created one
and all I'm going to do is essentially
for now I'm just going to put it here
like so
so there we go
right now it's in here but we will be
creating a DOT EMV file to keep it more
safe but you know I just wanna
get the basics done first and now let's
write our root
so
if we post
to the root let's say if we go to what
should we do localhost 8000 forward
slash completions this could be whatever
you want essentially all I'm saying is
that if we visit
forward slash completions then we will
get something back here okay uh and then
the Syntax for this I have a request and
a response
so put those in parenthesis this is
actually going to be an async function
because we're going to use the await
keyword inside of here but let's cross
that one we get to it we're going to do
try and catch so we're going to try
something and if it doesn't work we're
going to catch the errors I'm just going
to console error them out so console
error the error
okay
great and what we're going to try well
we're going to use the fetch keyword
make sure you are on the latest version
of node for in order to be able to use
the fetch API keyword on the back end so
just keep that in mind as well
so all I'm going to do is use the fetch
keyword and we're going to fetch to the
completions API
so once again let's go back here let's
go to the documentation
and we're going to use the chat
completions API from open AI so the
model we're going to use is I don't have
access to GP
gpt4 yet so I'm going to use gbt 3.5
turbo so let's go here and if we go into
chat chat completion not completion okay
chat completions this is the URL that
we're going to need
okay so I'm just going to make that
smaller here we go it's a post request
to this URL
so I'm just going to grab that and paste
it in like
so
next we're going to have to pass through
some options like what kind of request
is going to be so what method some
headers with our API key as well as
actually what what do we want to use and
the message we want to send over
so I'm going to Define that here const
options
it's going to be a whole object and like
I said it's going to take a method it's
going to be a post method as we
discussed and next we're going to pass
through some headers so the headers that
it's going to take well we need to
question some authorization so make sure
to spell this
so authorization and the authorization
is just going to be
um well a string with our uh const so
that's why I put back text so we can use
that code in here you have to put Bearer
and then that and then we're just going
to put some curly braces so that we can
pause through the API key so that's how
you'll put in variables you'd use the
dollar sign and the curly braces
okay next we're also going to have to
pass through the content type
so content type and then we're going to
put application
Json as we're going to be working with
Json and now we can Define the request
body so we're gonna have to pass this
through json's stringify okay and it's
going to be an object that we're going
to send through and we're going to
juicify it jsonify it thanks to Jason
stringify the model we're going to be
working with as I said I don't have
access to chat gpt4 but if you do please
go ahead and use that because the
results will be better I'm going to use
this model right here
and the messages we're going to pass
through are gonna be
so the role
is going to be user and then content
well the content for now let's just put
how are you okay and we'll replace that
we're just going to check this works and
I don't want to go over 20 tokens I'm
going to limit my tokens so I can do Max
tokens 100 okay that will just mean
basically every string um
text prompt is tokenized if you want to
check how many tokens your string is
going to use you can check it before
using this on the open AI documentation
but I think just you know put a Max in
here just so you don't go over and use a
boil free credits and whatever
so there we go one thing that I will say
is that we can't pass over Json from the
front and to the back end unless you
have this right so if you're having any
issues when it comes to that make sure
you have this that's very important
okay
great so those of all my options that
we're going to pass through with this
URL like I said this fetch API is an
async method which is why we're gonna
have to await it so we're literally
going to wait for uh something to come
back and we're going to save it under
response
and because we're using the 08 keyword
in here this whole function let me see
an async function again check out my
full site developer course if you want
to learn more about this in more detail
so now once we get the response we're
going to wait for it and then we get it
back
I'm going to get us to Json but uh oh
Jason is another async method so we're
going to have to await this to I'm going
to await it and once we get it back
we're going to save it as data
great and let's just send this over to
localhost 8004 slash completions by
passing it through
rest set
so now let's check it out
so first off after you've done this
let's hook this up to the front end I'm
going to do so with an on click so on
here if we click this div
I want something to happen and I just
want to get
message okay that's all I'm gonna do and
find me videos doing messages as it
could be plural and let's define it up
here so right under here we're going to
Define get messages
so cons get messages
it's going to be an async function
because we're going to use the fetch
keyword in here too
and once again we're going to use try
and catch so try
and we're going to catch any errors
and what are we gonna do this time
well first off we're just going to
console uh raw any errors and in here
once again we're going to use the fetch
keyword so await fetch I'm going to pass
in the URL this time though we're going
to get it from our back end so right
here that's what we're going to get it
from
so paste that in like so and again we're
going to have some options because we're
going to have to pass through the some
data right so exactly what we're writing
into the input
so that's the final options again
the method is going to be a post method
the body this time is uh I'm just going
to actually pass through a message and
it's going to have a value but at the
moment well yeah we can we can pause it
through let's just put hello how are
useful hard coding it and we're gonna
have to wrap this through Json stringify
again so Json stringify and I'm going to
get that whole object and positive
okay great
and I'm just going to add headers as we
are working with Json so I'm going to
put content
type
application
Json
okay wonderful so once again we're going
to wait for the response
and once we get the response we're going
to get it Json and let's save it as data
just like so and then for now I'm just
going to Contour look the data
so let's test that out so at the moment
we're just hard coding hello you that
will be passed on to the server but
we're not doing much with it because
we're just going to send how are you
from here anyway
so let's just try this out
so here
if I click on here I don't need to put
anything in
we're just going to wait
uh the promise is pending why is that
that's because we didn't wait
so you need to wait for that to come
back that's why we got a promise there
that's try again
and great so we get back this whole
object okay everything is working
and if you look in the object and we
look under choices and we look under the
first item in the array we get a message
from the assistant saying I'm an AI
language model so I don't have feelings
like humans do but I'm functioning
properly and ready to assist so we're
getting about that message next thing we
want to do is actually show that message
in here instead of card coding how are
you we want to actually get the input
right so let's do it well first off I'm
just going to save that response so the
whole message to State and for that we
need uh use state from react so I'm
going to import
use State and while we'll add it use
effects as I know I will need that from
react
so now if I want to save that message I
can go const
message
set message
use State and let's start off with being
null and so now at the moment we get and
I'll go we assigned the value of an L2
message and if you want to say it change
sorry the value of a message we use that
message to do it so I do want to change
the value so I'm just going to use set
message
and what I'm going to do is go into the
data get the choices so just like we did
before go into that orega the first item
and get the
message
right so once again here's my whole
object so that's technically data you go
into choices get the first item of that
array so zero
right zero and then we get the message
so the message will actually be an
object that has the content and the role
okay I want to save both
so let's carry on
so we don't need to console this app
anymore the message with the role and
the content is being saved under the
constant message so it's not a string
it's an object
okay so what do we say we want to do
next right we want to hook up the input
so let's say the value of up here to
Value set value
use State null and we're going to
override the value if we interact with
the input so let's find that input here
we go
we're going to display the value so
whatever the value is right now we're
just going to assign to the input at the
moment it's null of course but on change
of this input well I'm just gonna
pass through the event
I'm going to set value to wherever e
Target value is of that input
right
so now up here if I consult
log value just anywhere just above the
return
and I type something
to get up our console log
see that's what technology console login
value or console login app line 27 and
it will change
so that is how we are changing the value
constant okay and next let's actually
whatever state is at I want to send it
over so currently I would send over this
let's hook that up
so what I would do this is super simple
all I would do is get rid of this string
and put the value instead
okay and now deposit to our back end
we're passing it through with the body
we need this to be here in order for
this to work so don't forget that and
that just means that instead of having
this here I can get the request body
message
and pass that through like so and that
will now be sent over to open AI
okay
so again if this doesn't make sense
check out my full sites available course
I don't want to keep banging on about it
but you know there's a lot of stuff
we're doing here that if a beginner will
be way too much so do check it out
so now the one last thing I'm going to
do well I'm just going to console log
the
message that we get back so that's saved
on the message and try it out so let's
do what is
two plus two
send that
and great we get four and it's from the
assistant from the AI assistant so let's
now use this in order to create a chat
response okay as a list item so let's do
it
so let's go back in here
and what I'm going to do is actually
save all the previous chats
and you set previous chats in order to
change that and I'm going to start off
with this being an empty array this time
okay
so that's what I'm going to do and I'm
going to actually get this whole message
so whatever's coming back here right now
because I've got the raw and content and
I'm also just going to assign a title so
that I can essentially say that okay
this chat has this title I'm going to
lump it together how is this chat just a
new chat I'm going to give it a new
title and it's just going to be the uh
current the first prompt that we give
our chat
so let's do it let's do this maybe in a
use effect
okay
so just like so and I'm going to say
that anytime the message changes so
whatever we get back from the open API I
want this to run
I'm also going to save the current title
so current title
Set current title
use state
instead of as being an empty array as
well
so I'm also actually going to change
this if the current title changes so
whatever the prompt for the chat
whatever the start of the chat changes
then we run this again
so let's just console log the current
title the value so the input value and
the message that comes back to us
okay just so we can see a little bit
more of what is going on
great then you said
so what do I want to do well if there's
currently no current title right so if
there's no new title we don't have a
chat however
we do have a value in our input and we
do have a message that has come back to
us where then I want to set the current
title to be whatever the value is
right so hopefully that makes sense and
once we save it we can add it to the
history however
if there is a current title already that
exists and the value exists in an input
and we get the message back
so we're on the chat currently we're
still chatting away we just want to set
previous chats and we're going to
essentially get whatever's in that array
already right
and this is how you would update an
array using use state
I would open up the array I would get
the previous chats and spill them out
but then I'd also add I'm going to add
an object I'm actually going to add two
objects
so just like so
maybe I'll put this on a new row so it's
more readable for you
there's one object
and here is another object
is going to have the title
and the title is going to be the current
title so whatever the first prompt was
the role is going to be the user
so essentially us and the content
is going to be the value so I'm using
kind of what open AI gave me in terms of
structure for the object but I've added
my own title so we can save it to State
and then I'm literally just going to get
what churches if you get back to me so
roll
I'm gonna go into the message and get
the role
and I'm going to get the content and get
the message content okay and I'm also
just going to give this the title of the
current title so let's just talk this
through so every time we are saving
previous chat so a new chat I'm saving
whatever we ask the AI and we're signing
the role as us the user and I'm just
going to say the current title to me
show that all the chats are lumped by
the first prompt and I'm also sending
over the other object which is the
response from the AI which we've saved
under the constant message right that
was an object that had a role and
content and I'm literally just getting
the role from that object I'm getting
content from that object and assigning
it to role and content for my previous
chats state
I'm going to show you what this looks
like
okay
so there we go we have a few more things
to do and that is actually set the
uh history by the current titles so
let's go ahead and do that here
so here's my section of Main
and actually let's just show this if
there's car if there's no current title
then we show this however if there's a
current title then we get rid of that
and here we're going to map out onto
list items however maybe let's just see
what this looks like at the moment I'm
just going to console log out previous
chats
okay
so that's what we're gonna do
so let's go back here I'm just going to
let's start a new chat what is five plus
five
ask it
okay so that is essentially these are my
previous chats we've created an object
that has the content of what we asked it
as the user there we go
the title is an empty array that is
strange we need to essentially change
that current title and then our second
object the content is 10 because that's
the answer that we got back from the AI
and the role of the AI is a system
so why is title saving as an empty array
that is because the current title we did
set this to be an empty array this
should actually be null because we're
just going to save a text prompt and
where do we set the current title
well essentially this should have done
it for me because we're listening out
for current title changes and if there
is no current title which technique that
is not okay because before is an array
that didn't run let's try that again
so
what is five plus five
let's click on that
okay and great now our title gets
populated with the prompt itself and
both of them have that prompt right and
now because current title exists we will
miss this because current title does
exist and we'll just keep adding to the
chat right so let's ask another question
are you sure
foreign
because I asked it another question so
there's me asking are you sure as the
user the title is still the same the
first initial prompt and then we're
getting the response okay from the
assistant so great so this is good
however what if I want to change it I
want a new chat so if I click here I
essentially want to clear this title so
let's do it
so I'm going to make a uh handle click
function that I'm going to attach or
maybe let's call it something else so on
the button on click
I'm going to
create new
chat so let's define it
so up here
const create
new chat
I'm going to set message I'm just going
to clear everything set message so
whatever the message is from the uh
AI I'm going to set that to null I'm
going to set the value of the input to
an empty string so we're clearing that
and I'm going to set the current title
to be null 2 so I'm essentially
completely clearing it so we can start
fresh
okay so shall we have a go at
this
let's try it out
what is one plus one that's send that
over
okay so we get that there the title is
assigned but if I start a new chart and
go how are you
and send that over
okay the title has changed so great so
now if we ask more questions
the title of that should be
still attached to
how are you
and it is so great now I'm going to get
the unique title so we're going to get
everything and we're going to filter by
the unique title and show it in the
history as well as show the chat up here
so what I'm going to do is get the
previous charts and I'm going to use
filter
and I'm going to look at each previous
chat individual you can go this whatever
you want it's essentially every item in
my array and I'm going to literally just
look at the previous chat objects title
and if it equals the current title that
we are currently on well then we know
that we're on the current chat so let's
save these filtered items as current
chat objects any object that has the
title that is the same will be lumped
into current chats and this just means I
can then get current chats with the feed
okay and map out
each let's call it maybe a chat message
we're going to have to use an index as
we are mapping so let's put that index
here like so
and then
I'm just going to map onto a list item
uh we of course need to give it a key so
I'm just going to use the index
for that for this demo
and then I'm just going to essentially
I'm just going to spell key correctly
and put that there
put in two things into my list item
element I'm going to put in two P tags
this one's gonna show you who sent the
message so roll either it's the user or
the AI assistant and here I'm just going
to show the content of that message I'm
going to go chat message
great and let's just give this the class
name of
row so it's really obvious
okay and we can pick it out later
so this is looking good to me let's just
check that that contract exists fast
before mapping anything onto here and
while we are here I'm also just going to
get all the unique titles I'm going to
filter I'm going to get all the messages
and just get the unique titles because
as we saw there's some titles that have
like numerous right we just want
essentially to filter them all out and
just give return this title and this
title and put them in an array for us so
I'm going to show you the code to do
that
well this time we're actually going to
get the previous charts and we're going
to map
foreign
chat individual
and we're just going to get the previous
chat
title and now I can pass it through so
all of this I'm going to pass that
through into a new set
and make an array from it so array from
just like so and this will give me the
unique title so that piece of code is
super useful if you want to get unique
uh items from an object so if I console
log this out now
unique titles on line 61
you will see I've just got those uni
titles and put them in an array great
because now I can map them on into the
history
so let's get those unique titles and
instead of having blur I'm going to get
the unique titles
and if they exist I'm gonna map each
unique title
so maybe we get the index
so put that in parentheses like so
I'm just going to get that unique title
and pass it through here as code like so
wonderful
I believe that should be it we just need
to give this a key
and it should now look like this so it
doesn't look great at the moment we
still need to style stuff up
but
now
let's actually maybe add an on click so
that if we select a chat then we
essentially uh pass through that chat
that we click on as the current title
right because we want to change the
current title to the other chat so I'm
going to define a function for this
const and or click
and if we click on any one of those
so
handle click is assigned to the list
item in history so in here so we'll do
it on here on click we're going to call
the function handle click
and we just want to click on it so if we
click on the first unique title I'm just
going to pass through the unique title
that we clicked on so now we need to
make this a callback function as we just
call that again
so we're gonna pass it through into here
that you need Title and we're just going
to set
current title to be whatever title we
clicked on
right so hopefully that makes sense it
will do in a bit so that's what we're
gonna do and we're also just going to
set message to null and set value to now
okay so we're just starting fresh
great so let's just test it out
what
is four plus four
send so that should now get assigned to
here great and we can click on it and my
why is my content not showing up
let's have a look let's go down here
uh chat message this should be content
right because that's what we saved it as
here role and content and that's what
we're mapping out so now if we look in
here there we go user what is four plus
four assistance is eight and I obviously
pressed it twice because I'm getting it
twice so let's just try again what is
four plus four
send
great
are you sure question mark
okay and that's my assistant's answer
and then I'm just going to start a new
chat and this time how are you
okay so that's my question and that's
the assistant's answer but if I want to
swap back and carry on this conversation
you are great
then I can and it will be assigned to
here it does not get added to here
so great this is looking so good and if
I clear it we just get on your GPT this
is wonderful a few more styling things
that just style up these messages next
so all I'm going to do is style up
essentially this list item here
so let's do it
so down here I'm going to first style up
the feed I'm just going to give it a
scroll so I'm going to go over for
scroll so we can scroll through the
messages if we get loads I'm going to
make sure that the width is 100 and I'm
also going to just give it a padding of
zero so it's really squashed up to the
edges next any list item that lives
inside my feet
so just like that
I'm going to use display Flex so I'm
initializing flexbox so they appear next
to each other rather than stacks and the
background color I'm just going to go
with
the width I want it to be a hundred
percent and I'm going to give it some
padding of 20 pixels and I'm going to
space out each list item top and bottom
by 20 pixels and zero from the left and
right
okay so at the moment it looks like this
this is looking good let's just uh
assign a line the text a little bit
better so again I'm just going to say
that any P element that lives inside of
my feed is gonna have the color of rgba
so a bit more transparent I'm going to
go with white
0.8 opacity
I'm going to get the font size
of 14 pixels and I'm going to text a
line
left
and if that P element also happens to
have the class of roll I'm just going to
assign it A Min width of 100 pixels
so that we go this is looking so good
right now you can of course add images
in here instead of just use an assistant
like the actual app does but I think
this is looking fantastic there are a
few things you can do to clear this up
for example I do use RGB uh and hex
colors in here so please go ahead and
change that but overall now you know how
to use the open AI API and you know how
to make this cool chat gvz clone that
has a history that you can kind of move
back and forth to and add to the history
and create new chats with as well
finally we're just going to hide this so
I'm just going to stop this from running
and import a package called dot EnV so
just like that and we're just going to
create a new file so new file on the
same level as the server.js so e and V
just like that and we're going to Define
our API key so instead of having it here
I'm just going to take it you don't have
to put it as a string that is implied
just paste it in and now that means that
I can just use process EnV API key and
of course we need to require that
package so fire
dot EnV config and just start this up
again okay so just do that that should
now be picked up from this dot EnV file
okay so you don't upload this dot EMV
file onto GitHub great
so great I hope you have a bad fun
please take this to the next level you
know add new features it's yours
okay so we have learned a lot but I'm
really excited about showing you this
section because in this section we're
going to use open AIS daily model to
generate images for US based on text
prompts as well as create variations of
images if we choose to upload an image
and so much more so with this image API
we can create images from scratch based
on some text we provide as mentioned we
can also create edits of an existing
image based on some tags we provide and
we can of course create variations of an
existing image that we upload as well as
mentioned in the intro so let's check it
out
so once again let's get our end point we
will start off using this endpoint right
here
we will pass through our API key and
this time we don't need a model what we
provide however that is required is a
text prompt that is a string this text
prompt is passed through with the
request body along with some optional
things however this time these optional
things vary
so we can pass through n and this will
represent the number of images to
generate and this takes an integer and
we can do anything from one to ten so we
can essentially get 10 images back if we
want we can also pass through this size
and this will generate a specific size
of image and we have three options to
our disposal so three squares 256 512 or
1024 multiplied by itself we can even
have a response format which will
specify how our images returned with the
URL being default if nothing is put in
as well as the user to identify our end
user if we need
so let's run it
okay so let's do it as always here's my
file structure I've got an index HTML
file that is linking my app.js file and
there's nothing in here at the moment we
are going to be making a request to the
image Generations endpoint okay so
that's what we've been talking about
we're going to be generating images from
prompts and to do that we are going to
have to well get the fetch keyword and
pass through that endpoint here along
with the options and first off though
let's do this in a function this is
going to be an async function so I'm
going to call it asyn function fetch
images as that's what it's going to be
doing
so now let's also Define our API key up
here so we can communicate with open Ai
and I'm just going to paste it through
as a string and I'm just going to move
that in here now the endpoint that we're
going to be using is this one right here
so make sure yours looks the same and
the options well the method is going to
be a post method
the headers are going to hold our API
key so we're going to use authorization
right station and then we're gonna pass
through Bearer okay so capital B and
then I'm going to just put some code in
here so we're just going to do API key
like so make sure that those are back
ticks
great now we're going to have the
content type and the content type what's
going to be application Json as we are
working with Json so just make sure to
put that there next in the body is what
we actually want to send to the API and
we're going to pass through a object
right and the object is going to take a
prompt as we saw that is required I'm
going to go with a hamburger
singing in the ring you can put whatever
you want we do have to wrap this in Json
stringify so let's just put the whole
object in here okay so make sure you're
grabbing the whole object and just
pasting it in like so
so the prompt is required we can also
specify how many we want I'm going to
say I want two images and this size this
is going to be from the sizes that we
saw so there's a few options right as we
saw from the previous slide 1024 by 1024
was one of them great
so now let's await this let's save this
response
just like so and now I'm going to get
the response and get it Json
and once we get that we're going to wait
for that to come back to us and we're
going to get the data so now let's
consult the data I'm just going to do
console log data and now let's call this
so this gets called immediately when we
open the page so I'm just going to open
this up in the browser and let's inspect
to see what has come back to us so let's
just inspect this page and ta-da we get
an object we get an array of two images
so now if I grab this URL over here I'm
just going to grab that whole thing
let's go ahead and make that a little
bit bigger maybe so just copy it and
make sure not to have the quotation
marks at the beginning and end because
we need this to be a URL
in the rain and we get two of them
now great for those of you who just want
the hamburgers quickly however I'm just
going to show you how to do this with a
car command as always
so here is my car command as you will
see that is the end points that we are
going to we're just gonna have to put in
a prompt so once again let's put
hamburger
singing in the
rain and then let's put in our API key
so once again just as always just make
sure to get rid of that including the
dollar sign and just hit enter and wait
for that one image to come back we pass
through one end right here and the size
of the image here too so we should get
back one image of a hamburger singing in
the ring and there we go so let's grab
that URL let's paste it in here like so
and another hamburger singing in the
ring wonderful let's move on
Now using the darling model we can also
do image variation the image variation
endpoint looks like this and it will
allow us to get an existing image and
get up to 10 variations of it here are
what we can pass through with the body
as you can see an existing image is
required and all the others are optional
and will defer to a value if nothing is
provided I'm not going to be showing you
how to do that here because we're going
to be doing this in a project as it is a
lot more involved and will involve us
having to have existing images in our
projects so we'll do that when the time
comes
another thing we can do with the dialing
model is make image edits this would
involve using this endpoint right here
we are not going to be doing this in
this course but I did want to just flag
this as something you can do it would
evolve using an existing image a
potential mask so another image you want
to place on top of it along with a text
prompt to tell the open AI what you want
to do with these images to edit them
okay so that is just something you need
to know exists and if you're ready to
learn how to use the image generation
and image variation endpoints we're
going to be using them in two projects
coming up next
hey everyone and welcome to this video
in which I'm going to show you how to
use the Dali model from the open AI API
so essentially what we're going to be
doing is building an image generator
kind of like Dolly that's going to take
a text prompt and then it's going to
generate four images for US based on
that text prompt so super basic super
simple we're going to be building this
in JavaScript HTML and CSS so
essentially this is a beginner video for
those wanting to learn how to build
their own things using the open AI API
the powers tools such as dolly so what
are we waiting for of course this is a
front-end project so please don't go and
publish this code with the API key that
we will be using onto GitHub or share or
anything like that because if you do so
I'm going to take your API key and steal
your credits or you know if you have a
credit card attached they could
potentially rack up loads and loads on
your credit card bills so please keep
that API key safe this is just for demo
purposes if you want to learn how to
build out a more secure project we will
be doing that in another video where I
build a front end and a back end to keep
our API Keys safe
so let's do it please do have the
fundamentals of JavaScript down but if
you don't please do carry along anyway
I'm just filling your gaps of knowledge
later on after you finish this video
okay so let's do it we're going to build
this cool AI generator in JavaScript
HTML and CSS
so this is what it's going to look like
and then we can write a prompt and
generate four images from it and it's
going to have this cool background too
so I'm going to show you how to do that
as well so first off let's just start a
new project I'm using webstorm so I'm
simply going to click here and let's
call this Java Script AI image generator
just like so and create so that has
created a directory for me in a
directory called webstone projects and
now I could just create a new file I'm
going to call it index.html and then I'm
just going to create another file an
app.js file and now I'm just going to
create a final file it's going to be
Styles CSS just like so
so there we go there's our three files
all in the same folder and now let's
link them up
so here are some boilerplate code for
you I'm just going to go ahead and call
this AI image
generate door just like so
okay and now in the body oh well that's
where all my code is going to go but I'm
also going to link up the app JS file
thanks for script type this will be at
the bottom so after all our other
elements get uh red then we go to the
script tag and I'm just going to link up
the app.js file that's going to read our
JavaScript so the script is going to
read our JavaScript from this file
nurses also linked up the style sheets
so I'm going to use the link tag for
this uh it's a self-closing tag we'll do
row style sheet and as the href we're
also going to put the path to our Styles
CSS file which is just that as we don't
need to go any folders or anything like
that it's in the same location as this
index HTML file
so great that is looking good
now the background I'm just going to
show people how to do this as a lot of
people are probably curious
I'm just going to go to app hypey.app so
that's all I'm doing and now we can
generate our own way which is pretty
cool so I chose a layered wave and then
all I did was kind of you know play
around with this or you can just choose
your own like that or you can change the
balance the wave count the complexity
which will be like oh the contrast the
overlap and just so much more there's so
much to do and then just download the
SVG
and once that is done you can open it up
and then you inspect the page
like so
and then I'm just going to copy the
whole element okay so that SVG right
there so that's all I have done
okay and now if we go back here I'm just
going to
in the body paste it so it is very long
and that's what it looks like
let's just open this up in our browser
so I can go ahead and click here if I
want if I am using webstorm
or if you are not you can just
copy
the path copy the absolute path and then
paste it in like so so both things are
okay to do
great now let's get rid of the little
like water around it and make this
stretch right so let's do it so actually
on here well I am going to do is the
width and the Heights I'm just gonna go
with using the width and height from
here
and then as the width here I'm just
going to go 100 viewport width and then
this is going to be a hundred viewport
height we could have picked this out and
done in the CSS file so that is totally
fine too and on here I'm going to grab
the body and just get rid of any default
uh padding and margin just like so so
then it should look like that so that is
much better now now so there we go
that's how you would use it so that is
how I like it at the moment
I'm actually just going to take the one
I previously generated because I think I
prefer it but that is how you will get
your one once you're happy with it once
you've played around with it I don't
play around with this one that much and
I just thought the other one looked
cooler so I'm just going to replace mine
with the previous one that I made
okay
and great like I said it's super long so
yeah I mean not much difference but I
just think like that looks better okay
and now as the background I'm just going
to make it the same color as this last
color right here so let's find out what
that is in fact I'm just going to
inspect this
so the color for this is that
and now I'm just going to
assign that to the body as well just so
that in case you know someone kind of
zooms out like I did then it just looks
much better I prefer that a lot more
okay let's carry it on
so what is the next thing that we're
going to do well we're going to add some
elements in here
so I'm just going to make sure I format
that correctly
I'm going to next add a header
and that header well I'm just going to
put the H1 element of Ania AI image
generator of course you can replace this
with whatever title you would like and
then after the header I'm going to have
one section and this is going to hold
all my images so I'm going to give it
the class name of
images section
and then let's have another section
this one's going to have the
class of
input container
just like so
and I'm actually going to put in the
input here
okay
and then a div and I'm going to overlap
this div later on which is why I put
them both in an input container and
let's give this div the ID of
submit
icon just like so
and I'm just going to put some text
symbol in here if you would like to use
it you can get it at this URL it's just
this little arrow that looks like this
so you can get it from here if you would
wish
okay so at the moment our
out and our title are showing up here
that's because we need to
stuff and use display Flex to Center
everything in here in a much nicer way
so let's do it
so we are done with this for now we are
not going to put in any images because
we're going to use JavaScript in order
to do that for us
so let's carry on
now we are going to essentially on the
body well I just want to make sure that
everything is stacked on top of each
other so I'm going to initialize flexbox
so that I can use flex Direction column
okay without this I won't be able to use
this next I'm just going to set the
width and the height of the browser so
view width is going to be a hundred
percent of the viewport width and the
height is going to be 100 of the
Viewpoint height okay and that means I
can now use justify content Center and
align items Center okay to Center
everything to the very center of my
browser again I need to assign a width
and a height in order for
um these two work properly so now
everything should be in the center just
like so okay and we want to disclude the
SVG from this so I'm just going to grab
the SVG and I'm going to essentially
just give it a position
absolute top zero left zero okay and I'm
just going to make sure that it's always
behind everything so I'll just give it a
Zen x minus one or minus 10 to be sure
why not
okay great so now that is in the center
amazing the other thing I want to do is
just uh maybe in the header this time I
just want to make sure that all font in
the header is going to be white so let's
go with color
let's go to RGB
255-255. so that we got so that is
something that I have done great let's
also assign a height so I'm just going
to hard code a height of 150 and I'm
going to Center everything in it by
initializing flexbox again and now I'm
just going to align items Center
so this time it's going to center it on
the opposite axis so from top to bottom
so at the moment it will look
wonderful so this is looking great
now what other things that I want to do
what I'd quite like to space out all the
child elements of the body so excluding
the SVG that would be the header and the
two sections and I would like them to
the spacing to be even between them so
I'm going to use justify content space
between
so on the body
I'm going to change this to be space
between
so they are spaced out like so
wonderful
this is looking great
the other thing I'm going to do is just
change the font family on the whole body
itself and let's go with a tribute
Ms and as a backup I'm gonna have Sans
serve so just one backup so that will
just change the text to be a little bit
more uh like this
next let's style up so the images
container maybe let's leave that for now
let's do the input container next
okay so let's do it in fact I think the
input container let's wrap it in a
another
wrapper
so in fact let's make a section and I'm
going to give this the class of bottom
section just so that we can uh
Center this whole input container inside
of it so maybe let's change this to be
18 instead okay so there we go so now if
we look in here the three child elements
are the header the section and this
section as well so let's pick out the
bottom section of course we are
discounting the SVG as we've positioned
that separately to the rest
so here I'm just going to minimize that
I'm just going to grab the element with
the class name of bottom section and I'm
just going to make sure that the width
of it is a hundred percent of the parent
element
and let's also use display Flex
initialize flexbox so that we can then
use justify content Center to Center
everything from left to right and I'm
also going to assign this a height of
150 pixels
so there we go there's our bottom
section and there's our header again
header
bottom section
wonderful
let's work on signing the child at the
bottom section next which is the input
container so again I'm just going to
grab the input container by the class
name so the whole element that has the
class name of input container and I'm
just going to make sure that the width
is a hundred percent but I'm also going
to give it a Max width so that it stops
at 650 pixels if we wanted to okay I'm
also going to give a position of
relative this is because I want to
position the child inside of it
relative to the parent by using position
absolute on it so what I mean is
well if we grab the item with the class
of submit icon and I give it a position
of absolute and I actually fix it so
let's go ahead and fix it to the parent
so the input container Top by 10 pixels
and right 30 pixels where do you think
it will go
well he is the parent it will go 10
pixels from the top of that blue square
and 30 pixels from the right of it
so there essentially
okay
great
now let's also style the input itself so
let's grab the input and I'm also going
to give it a width of a hundred percent
so just like so
maybe let's change this to be a bit
smaller so 600 pixels I'm also going to
give this a border of none as I don't
want to border I'm going to make sure
that the font size in here is 20 pixels
so quite uh large maybe or larger let's
cut it out by 10 pixels I'm also going
to add a radius
to smooth off the edges and that's going
to be of five pixels and I'm going to
add some box Shadow because why not I'm
going to RGB
uh let's go with this kind of dark color
so 38 57 77
0 on the x-axis 20 pixels on the y-axis
30 pixels blur and minus 10 pixels red
okay and at the moment it will look like
this however I want it to be on the
inside rather than it spilling over the
parent so for example I'm just going to
show you there's our bottom section
right the input uh container which holds
the input they're spilling over the
bottom section so I'm going to use box
sizing border box
stop that from happening
okay so now it is in the parent and
looks like this so much better let's
also make sure that the headers width is
also 100 percent
so that it takes with the whole space
and now we can also Center that title so
let's do justify content Center
okay
and wonderful so this is looking great
let's get to hooking this up with
JavaScript next
so let's do it
so all I'm going to do is in here I'm
going to show you how to get your API
key so we're going to need to go to open
AI so just make sure to go to open Ai
and click on API reference I've already
got it up here and now under here I'm
just going to view my API keys now I can
create a new key show so all I'm going
to do is create a new key like this and
that will get created for me
okay great and you're just going to copy
it and keep it safe okay you don't want
anyone stealing this because they could
use all your free credits or rack up
money on your credit card if you have a
credit card attached to this and you
could of course delete them if you think
yours is compromised or you just don't
want them anymore
so make sure to do that I'm just going
to save it here so const API key
like so make sure it's your string and
I'm just going to remind you to
not put this on hit GitHub okay do not
deploy this API key or up node onto
GitHub okay this is just for personal
use because of the issues that I said
before so there's our API key we've got
it now let's get to using it
so what I'm gonna do is well first off I
want to essentially get an image if I
write something in the input and click
on this button right so let's pick out
this button by the ID
because we're going to touch an event
listener to it so I'm going to use
document
query selector I'm going to look for
anything with the i ID of submit icon
just like so and let's save it as submit
uh icon
so that we can work with it in our
JavaScript now so I'm going to get that
and I'm going to use add event listener
so listen Apple clicks and if we click
on it I want to get images
okay so now let's define the function
get images
so cons to get images I'm just using a
function expression you can write
function if you want
and what we're going to do is try
something and catch the errors if it
doesn't work
error
and we'll just consult erroring
the error so that's all I'm going to do
so if we click on that seven icon so if
we click on it that's the event we're
going to call this function at the
moment it's not doing much because you
know we need to write this code
so what we're going to do is make a
request
okay we'll go to make a request to the
Dali model
and that is to API references and then
we're going to find images okay so this
is what we need it's a post request to
this URL so let's grab this URL
and now I'm going to use the fetch API
keyword to fetch from this URL I'm gonna
have to pass through some options in
which we Define the method which is
going to be post as we just saw so const
options
method
is going to be a post method
and next we're going to also have to
pass through some headers right because
we're going to have to pass through that
API key and we're going to do so
we're going to write authorization make
sure to spell that correctly
authorization and then we're going to do
back ticks as we're going to use the
word Bearer and also pass through that
API key so to pass through code or
variables we use the dollar and these
two uh curly braces and then we're going
to pass through the API key so that will
come out because Bearer and this string
with a space
next we're also going to have to define
the content type because we're working
with Json so content type and then we're
going to do app location
okay son okay so that's what we have
done and then we're gonna have to have
the body so the body well I'm just going
to pass through an object and it's going
to have a few things it's going to have
the prompt itself so the string that we
want to send to the AI so like generate
a cat or something so we're going to put
that here next we're going to have n
which is going to be the number of
images we want I'm going to put four and
then we're going to have to have the
size and the size of this is going to be
well there's three we can choose from if
you look here here are the options Only
The Prompt is required right so the make
us a cat these are optional but I divide
n as four because I want four images and
the size we can choose from these three
I'm just going to choose the biggest you
can have all these others but you know
as a default we are going to be
returning the URL to the image and I
don't really care about the user being
shown for that
so great so let's put in this size as
that is the options we need and I'm
gonna have to wrap this through Json
stringify
okay so there's a method called Json
stringify and then we're going to pass
through this whole object through it so
that it kind of justifies this for us
so there we go now the prompt of course
I can write some text but that's not
very fun I want to get the value from
this uh input right so let's go ahead
and do that there's only one input so
I'm just going to pick it up by the
element itself document query selector
and I'm going to look for an input
okay and let's save this as input
element
just like so so now I can grab that
input element and whenever we click on
it let's hope there's something there
right because input element and we're
going to get its value
okay so when we click on the little
arrow we hopefully have something in the
element otherwise you know you're just
sending an empty string and then we're
also sending through the amount of
images you want and the size of those
images
so great so those are the options so
we're passing through the URL and the
options as a second parameter fetch is
an async function so we need to use the
awake keyword for this range or wait for
it to come back and as we're using the
await keyword in here this also needs to
be amazing function
so if you want to know more information
on that I do have some async await
tutorials on my channel
so once that comes back we're going to
save this whatever comes back to us
under the const response
okay so we're getting the response and
once we get that response we're going to
get the Json from it but oh this is also
an async method we're gonna have to
await it so we're going to await that
Json and say the return on that data and
for now let's just console
log
later so there we go let's check it out
so all I'm going to do is back on here
let's go
pictures of blue cats in the rain
and click
it's gonna have a console log as well
okay so that is done and we get four URL
this is great and if I get one of these
URLs and put them in here
we get a picture of a blue cat in the
rain it's so sad
wonderful so this works I'm also gonna
just add a cursor to this so on the
actual submit
icon I'm going to add cursor
pointer just so it's obvious that we can
click on it so that that should show up
wonderful
so now let's get to using these URLs and
mapping them onto images here so let's
do it
so I think once we get that data right
so data exists we're going to get the
data from it because if we was looking
here I'm just going to click on this
again a blue cat
okay and let's wait for that to do its
thing we want to just see what returns
back to us so we can work with it
this is data we then need to go into dot
data right to get this whole array so
that's why I've gone data dot data if
data exists we're going to go into data
and get that whole array and for each
item in that array what should we call
each item we can call it whatever we
want I'm going to call an image object
as that's essentially kind of what it is
right it's a
object that holds just the URL so for
each of those I'm going to actually
create an element so I'm going to use
document create element and I'm going to
create a div that's right that's what
I've done and let's save this as image
container
because each of my images I'm going to
put on a container so that we can kind
of crop it out if it's too big so now
let's grab that in which container and
I'm going to give it the class
list
ad and I'm going to create a class that
is called image
container okay so that's what I'm going
to do and once we have that image
container
uh we're actually going to put a another
element a a image element inside of it
so let's create it document create
element
image and let's call this image element
and now let's grab the image element and
I'm going to use set attributes so
JavaScript method is called set
attribute to set the source and then
whatever the image object URL is
okay so I'm getting the URL and I'm
essentially getting the image object and
adding Source equals the image URL and
now I'm going to get that image
container and I'm going to append I'm
going to put in that image
element into it okay and once that is
done I'm actually just going to pick out
the whole
image section by its class name so let's
do that I'm going to do so up here const
image
section equals
document query selector and I'm going to
look for something with the class of
image section so then I'm going to grab
that image section and I'm going to
append that image container I just
stuck the image into
okay so let's have a look at what this
looks like before continuing right
so maybe let's get rid of this console
log now
go in here
and a orange
hot dog
it's a way for that to do its thing
and great so obviously we haven't styled
it at all but I'm just going to show you
what happened so this images section
which at the beginning had nothing in it
now has four elements inside of it it
has a div we created a div for every
item in that array right we created the
div and we gave it the class list out of
image containers we added the closet
image container to it next we also
created an image element and we added
the attribute so set attribute of source
and a URL that we are mapping over so
that's what we did and then we put that
image element in the element with the
closet image container and then we put
that image container inside the image
section so we did all that with
JavaScript which is pretty cool
so now we have our four images and let's
just style this up
so what I'm going to do is perhaps grab
the
let's grab the
images section so let's go ahead and
grab that
and I'm just going to say that the width
of this whole section is going to be 100
but also I'm going to set a Max width
and it's going to be 600 pixels so just
like our input and now I'm going to use
display Flex to initialize flexbox and I
want everything to wrap over each other
so I'm going to use flex wrap graph in
order for it to do that and then I'm
just going to space out everything
evenly with space between and also just
pair this out by 10 pixels
okay
great
and finally I'm just going to do a few
more things so I'm going to grab the
image container so the thing that holds
our image and I'm just going to give it
a width of 40 of the parent so the image
section so each one's only 40 I'm going
to round off the edges with border
radius let's round off by 15 pixels uh
let's hide any overflow so if it's a
square the image is a square that is
inside of it I want to hide off those
edges and let's just give a box Shadow I
want to go with RGB 38 57 77 as the
color and then zero x axis 20 pixels
y-axis 30 pixels blur and minus 10
pixels spread and finally I'm going to
save any image please inside of the
image container and let's just give it a
width
of a hundred percent okay great maybe
let's change this to be 48 I think 40 is
maybe too small and let's test it out
and just make sure that you know you are
using the same quote marks everywhere
just
for sharing this with anyone before you
don't need them here so let's get rid of
those
so we can do that just cleaning this up
a little bit and this should be small so
let's just change that also
and then just make sure that
if you are using hex and RGB just try to
make sure that it's the same uh approach
you use each time
so great that is looking so much better
I'm just going to change these out to
just to make everything a bit more
consistent rather than just me speed
coding this through for you
okay
Let's test it out
what should we do let's do a rainbow ice
cream
and wonderful so I hope you've had fun
building this image generator of course
this is just for demo purposes we are
going to be building the same thing but
with added functionalities we're going
to be building a dolly clone that will
do this but also allow us to upload
existing images for variation in reacts
with a node.js backend as well as using
the open AI node.js library next
hi everyone and welcome to this tutorial
from Cape Town in South Africa and in
this video I'm going to be showing you
how to build a daily clone essentially
so an AI image generator that will take
prompts and generate images for you
we're going to be generating lots of
images based on this text prompt and
we're also going to add another feature
that allows us to take an existing image
and upload it and then create variations
of that image from it okay so really
excited about this because we're going
to be using the open AI API for this so
you're interested in learning how to use
it this is the perfect tutorial for you
we're going to be building this in react
for the front end with a node.js backend
so that we can keep our API Keys safe
so what are we waiting for of course if
you don't have the fundamentals
everywhere and node.js down please do
try this out anyway and fill in your
gaps of knowledge later on I do have a
course that covers all of this so check
out the link in the video description
below if you wish right so first off I'm
just going to start a new project it's
going to be a react project so all I'm
going to do is because I'm on webstorm
just click react and what should we call
this I'm just going to call it react
daily Club
okay and I'm essentially going to use
this command to spin up my project so in
webstorm I don't need to do anything I
just need to click create and then that
will spin up my react app now if you're
not using webstorm just go ahead I'm
just going to make this bigger and go to
the directory of your choice so for me
it's going to be worth some projects and
then do npx space so it's two commands
create
react app so just like we saw saw and
then whatever you want to call your
project so you can do react dolly
clone or whatever you want and hit enter
and that will do exactly the same as
what is happening here okay and then
you'd have to go into that project so CD
into this project and open it up so that
is just for those who are not using
webstorm okay but I am so I'm just going
to continue and wait for all my files
and configuration to populate in this
directory for me so that I can spin up a
react project
okay if this is a bit too much or if you
are new to reacts then please do check
out my full site developer course where
we go into this in a lot more detail
then I'm going into now of course I'm
just assuming that you have the
fundamentals downpour react but if you
don't then no worries please watch along
anyway and fill in the gaps of knowledge
later on so there we go happy how can we
are done and if we look in here we see
all the files and folders already for me
to use I'm just going to clean up and
delete the ones I don't need so let's
just go ahead and delete these because
we're not going to write any tests so
delete that delete the logo
delete delete delete anyway delete let's
go ahead and yes we don't want the test
file so that can go and I'm going to
delete the app CSS file because there's
not going to be much styling I'm just
going to do all in one file so now your
index.js file I'm just going to again
delete this because we don't need it I'm
going to delete semicolons because I
don't like using them
and there we
go so that is where your index GS file
should look like at the moment let's get
rid of everything in the index CSS and
your app.js again I'm just going to
delete most of this like so we don't
have a logo and we don't import the app
CSS file I'm also going to change this
to be a functional expression just
because that is my personal preference
so this is what your app JS files should
look like this is where your index CSS
file should look like and this is where
your index.js bar should look like you
can change this vjsx files as
essentially we are going to be using jsx
this is jsx that is totally up to you
I'm not going to because uh I just want
to get the project done for you so we
can learn how to use open AI but it's up
to you
so there we go that is what we have at
the moment let's carry on so first off
I'm just going to stir this up let's
work on actually generating images first
so let's do it so
what I'm going to do is just essentially
build a kind of input that looks kind of
cool and I'm going to do this by
essentially creating a section so we're
going to have two sections
we're gonna have this to be the search
section so I'm just going to give the
class name of search section just like
so and let's have another section and
it's going to be to show all our images
so I'm just going to give this the class
name of and let's go with image sections
what images are going to be Spilled Out
into here now in the search section I'm
also going just to put a p element that
says
start with a detailed description
and then I'm going to open up a span
element that says
surprise as well if we want to be
surprised with a prompt instead
so there we go or maybe let's just have
surprise me sir prize me
okay so that's what that is going to say
let's also just pick this out so I'm
going to give this the class name
of
surprise so we can pick it out so we can
style it surprise
I'm just going to put this on a new line
for you like so and also we're going to
have an on click on here but let's maybe
leave that or perhaps let's do it why
not let's have some options to be
surprised with so I'm gonna write
surprise
options just like so and make an array
and then in the surprise us options
let's have a few commands that we can
pass through so I'm just going to have
three strings in this array a blue
ostrich eating melon
let's have a Matisse
style shark
on the telephone
and tree to see what that's going to
look like a pineapple sun bathing
I'm looking at the sun now so I'm gonna
go with some bathing on an island
because I'm in Cape Town at the moment
and I've got the most amazing view of
the sea so I guess that's where that has
come from
ostrich hope you haven't made any sort
of mistakes so we are now have some
surprise options and what I want to do
is on click of this
I want to essentially bring back one of
these so we can populate it but let's
leave that for now I just want to carry
on building this out a little bit more
first
so there we have our P element that
whole thing right here it's going over
three lines and after our P element I'm
actually going to create a div
and it's going to hold our input as well
as the button to generate new ones so
I'm going to give this the class name of
inputs
container just like so
and in my input container I'm going to
have an input which is going to take up
the majority of the input container but
on the right of it I'm also going to
have a button that's going to say
generate and it's going to generate
whatever uh images we want based on the
prompts we give so those are my two
things that I'm going to put in here
maybe let's also have a placeholder for
this so just we know what kind and some
inspiration I guess for the prompt let's
have an impression nest
oil painting of a sunflower
in a purple vase dot dot dot again I'm
just going to put this on a new line
because I want you to be able to read
everything so that is one thing that
we're going to have on the input
and the button again there's going to be
an on click on here but other than that
I think we are now done we just need to
start this up a little bit so let's go
ahead and fast pick out the app first
off as well I'm going to also just grab
the whole body so the whole body of the
app that we are building let's make it a
bit bigger and I just want to get rid of
any default margin and padding so I'm
just going to go with margin 0
padding zero that's actually very large
we don't need it that big
uh I'm also just going to make sure the
whole body takes 100 of the viewport
width and a hundred
other viewport height
and then let's also give a background
color I'm going to go with a slightly
off-white so f a f a f c is what I've
chosen you can kind of see the preview
here and I'm just going to make sure
that all the text is also the same color
so this kind of gray there we go I'm
also just going to make sure that
everything so stormy is everything
everything in here is going to have the
font family
you can have a backup I can't be
bothered but if you want you can of
course have like a few more here as
backups to sunsera but Sans serif is a
pretty stable one I think all browsers
are compatible with it
so great so that is my body one other
thing that I'm going to do is actually
say
so at the moment let's start this up I
could just go ahead and click here and
that will run the command npm Run start
for me so this Command right here but if
you are not in webstorm of course you
need to go uh into webzone purchase
again and find react dolly
clone open AI
okay so just go ahead and do that making
sure to spell that correctly and once
you're in here you will do npm Run start
to start up that project again I don't
have to I'm just going to click here and
that will open that up for me so there
we go it's opening up on localhost 3000.
and there we go that's what it looks
like I'm going to inspect the page so we
can view the console and see what's up
so this is what it looks like at the
moment our elements are here
and if you move this down you will see
in the body okay we have the root and
the app is injected into there and then
we've got the search section and the
image section which doesn't have
anything in it at the moment but let's
start this up a little bit more
so I'm just going to minimize that and
keep that running and now let's get the
search
section just like so it's going to
minimize that and the search section I'm
going to make sure that the width is a
hundred percent uh and then I'm going to
Center everything in there so I'm going
to initialize flexbox and now I'm going
to do Flex direction to make sure that
everything sucks on top of each other so
like a column and I'm going to Center
everything using justify content Center
so at the moment
that is my such section everything is
centered from the top to bottom and now
what I'm also going to do is get the
parent so the app and make sure that
these two
uh are kind of not going all the way to
the sides I actually want the app to be
only 90 on the viewport width so let's
grab the app itself so the element with
the Clause of app and I'm going to sign
the width of 90
if you put
width to it
okay
and now just Center it in the body so
let's grab the body again
and use display Flex justify content
Center so now that should be centered so
great that is what it looks like at the
moment let's get to styling the span or
the classes surprise me next so once
again I'm just going to find the element
with the class of surprise
because that was a class we applied to
that and I'm just going to make sure
that the background color is a color
that I have picked out previously so
there we go
I'm going to make sure the font is black
I'm also just going to round it off so
it looks more like a pill by giving it
five pixels border radius so border
radius
I'm going to make the font weight a lot
heavier so I'm going to pass through 600
and let's give it a padding so I'm going
to pad out four pixels from the top and
bottom and 12 pixels from the left and
right so that is a shorthand to do that
so at the moment
it looks like this
and I'm also just going to apply some
margin to spacer out so I'm just going
to use margin 0 on the top zero on the
right but two pixels at the bottom and
five pixels on the left so that is what
it looks like at the moment this is
looking pretty good now let's style the
input container so what I'm going to do
is let's go back in here and have a look
at this let's grab the input container
so there we go the element with the
class name of input container
and I'm going to say that I want the
width of it to be 100 of the parent that
it's in so the search container
let's use display Flex to initialize
flexbox and that just means that
anything in the input container so the
input itself and the button will be next
to each other and now I just want to
round it off so give the whole thing a
border
radius of 6 pixels however it does have
an input inside and a button inside if
those two elements go over the outline
of the input container I want anything
that goes over to be hidden so I'm going
to do overflow okay then so that just
means that as you'll see here the little
Corners have been cut off because they
go outside the input container itself so
here's my input container and as you'll
see that has been cut off now let's
style the input and the generate button
next so let's do it
uh one last thing though is I am going
to add a box Shadow 2 here I'm going to
go RGB a for transparency I'm gonna go
zero
zero eighty two as the color and then
0.15 opacity and I'm going to apply zero
on the x-axis two pixels on the y-axis
four pixels blur and then uh zero spread
so we can't just leave that and this
cool box Shadow will be applied now
let's actually start the input so let's
grab the input
we can say that it's an input that lives
inside the input container just in case
we want to add different inputs later
and I'm just going to go with border
none
let's give a padding from the top 13
pixels and from each side 14 pixels
making sure this will panning correctly
and then the box size it I want this to
have one on the inside so I'm going to
use border box and the font size as well
I'm going to apply as 13 pixels or maybe
let's make a bigger 15 pixels with the
outline of the actual input being none
as well so this just means that let's
just comment this out for now this just
means at the moment you will see a blue
outline I want to get rid of that if I
interact with it which means I can out
outline none let's just make sure we
spell outline correctly for that to be
applied so now no Blue Line will be
applied great
so that is my input the other thing I
need to change is the width of it I want
to do 90 of the parent which is the
input container and let's just change
the font weight of this to be 200 as
well so there we go so if this is width
90 let's make the button that lives
inside the input container a width of
you guessed it a width of 10. and let's
style it up as well so at the moment it
will look like this but let's style it
up further so it looks less horrible
so
one other thing however is on the input
itself I'm just going to change the
placeholder text so if you ever want to
change the placeholder text you can so
at the moment obviously let's just click
off this it looks like that we can go
further
and just change the color to be a bit
lighter so I've gone ahead and picked
out this color like so and let's make
the font weight
um well 200 I think that's already
applied but it should just look like
this now
beautiful
okay so we have the button I'm also
going to just change the border of it to
be none
let's change it to have a border on the
left there so we're going to override
that none and give that border left of
one pixels the color that's kind of the
same as the color well exactly the same
as the text
placeholder color and make it solid
the background color of the button I
want it to be all white let me give it a
color so the text should be this color
uh let's make it bold so let's give it a
font weight of or you can go bold or you
can choose an exact formula that's up to
you and I'm going to make sure that we
it's obvious to someone that we can
click on it by adding Casa pointer so if
we go over it my cursor changes
okay
okay wait
so that is cool and let's just change
that if the button is active so let's
grab all of this and say that if the
button is active I just want to maybe
let's just change the background color
so background color and let's go with
this kind of color like so so if we
click on it it just does that but this
is good so far I'm really enjoying it
okay some generic stuff I'm going to add
is perhaps let's
just change all the P elements in here
to have a font weight that is applied as
like a default so font weight I'm going
to go with 200 and let's also change the
font size to be 14 pixels so that is
just going to be applied a little bit to
all of the
fonts as a default wonderful
okay
so I think this looks looking good for
now let's carry on
so I think it's now time to actually
generate an image so that we can see all
the images showing up so let's do that
next
for this I'm actually going to build out
a back end so in here I'm just going to
create a new file so on the same level
as the package Json I'm going to get a
file and call it server.js and our
server is essentially going to go on
here so there we go that is our file
there is where it lives just make sure
that it's not in the source directory
it's outside great so let's minimize
that now what's going to go in my
server.js file well let's set it up
we're going to have to define a port so
I'm going to go with Port 8000. we're
then going to have to acquire some
packages so cons Express equals and then
I'm going to get the package express so
I'm going to do require Express
as well as a bunch of other packages so
maybe now is a good time to actually
install those packages so if you get up
your terminal making sure that you're in
the correct project just do npmi and
we're going to install the package
express we're also going to install
calls so Express is going to help us
with routing cause is going to help us
with error messages that we get from
course we're going to use the dot EnV
file
so we need the dot interview package for
this in order to hide our secret
variable so we don't upload them onto
GitHub or anything like that and we're
of course going to use the open AI
package that will help us communicate
with open AI better as well as a page
called fs and motor which will help us
deal with actually storing images into
our projects but we'll come on to that
later for those of you who need more of
an explainer into these packages and
what we're doing here please do check
out my course where again I go into this
in a lot more detail there's just not
enough time for now and it really is the
kind of fundamentals of working with
Express and node.js so I'm going to hit
enter for that to do its thing
and essentially you should see those
dependencies or those packages show up
here along with the version we are using
so if your version is different for any
reason please go ahead and change that
and make sure that they're the same if
you're watching this in the future as
this video because something might not
work and then just write rerun it so
reinstall them again if you've already
changed the package so if I change the
package here to three save that file and
run npm that is the version that will
get installed but of course we don't
want that we want the latest versions
so great we have now installed those
packages
now I'm going to write a script in order
to start our backend so here is our
front end but I'm going to change it to
be start front end so I'm just going to
make that a bit bigger for you we're
also going to have to install one more
package which is no demand which is
going to listen out to constant changes
on our backend so please go ahead and
install that package which means we can
now use it to start our backend and
listening out to constant changes
so now I'm just going to do start
back end
and I'm going to do no demon another one
listen up for constant changes and I'm
going to say on which file I'm going to
say on the server.js file so server.js
so that's what that piece of code is
done and there's the nodemon package so
save that file and now I'm actually
going to stop this from running because
I'm going to run my front end from here
so I'm going to do npm Run Stop front
end this time npm Run Stop front and hit
enter so now our front end is running
again and you will see that is running
and I'm going to create a new tab making
sure again that I'm in the same project
and do npm run this time starts
back end and hit enter so there we go
now we have our back end running and our
front end running
so now back in here of course we need
the package express next I'm also going
to require the package course so let's
do require and then the package of
course
and now I'm gonna get Express because
essentially I've got the package and
I've saved it under this cons and now I
need to release all of that
wonderfulness so whoop that's me
releasing it and now we need to store
all that wonderfulness under something
else I've gone with app which means we
can now use all of Express's
wonderfulness by using app and now app
will have lots of cool methods and
properties attached to it one of them
being app used which will allow us to
grab the course package and once again
release all of its wonderfulness so we
can use it in this project
okay so hopefully I've explained that
well the other thing we need to do is
actually use app use and we're going to
get Express
and release jsons use the method of Json
on it so we can actually work with Json
when we're sending Jason from the front
of our project to the back end of our
project if you don't have this you won't
be able to send stuff on the front and
to the back end uh specifically Json
so great the other thing we need to do
is uh require
the
package.env and this will allow us to
essentially create dot EnV files to
store our variables secretly and we're
going to have to do that because we're
going to store our openai API key
cool so I think that should be it for
now we do have a few more to use but I
think Let's cross that path when it gets
to it so now I can of course use app and
it will come with a cool method called
listen which allows The Listener to
report so that is one thing we're going
to pass through and the second thing is
a call back and we're just going to
consort log
your server is running on Port and then
the port number okay
so let's check it out so now if I look
at my terminal that shows up and if I
make any changes here it will re-run it
so I just saved the project again and
let's rerun it so that's what node in
one does nodemone essentially listen
that's with constant changes on our back
end
go
so now that we have done that let's go
to using the open AI API
so all I am going to do is essentially
go to the open AI
documentation let's go to developers
let's go to API reference of course
making sure that you are signed in right
so I hope you're signed in and all I'm
going to do is essentially this is the
we're going to create images first
so this is going to help us we're going
to use the node.js for this and this is
the end point we're going to use to
create images we want to create 10
images so 10 is a number we can pass
through we can pass through the number
of images to generate we can get up to
10 so let's go get to it the other thing
we're going to pass through is the size
of the image it has to be one of these
three and then as a default response
we're going to get a URL to the image
that's fine we're not going to pass that
through in fact we're just going to pass
through the prompt which is required the
amount of images we want to get and the
size of the image so that's what we're
going to do it's already kind of done
for us here so all I'm going to do is
take all of this again make sure you are
logged in because we are going to have
to get our API key from here but
essentially here's the URL you need to
be at images create image and then under
create image make sure you're on node.js
and literally just copy all this code
and then we're just going to write a
root
so what's the route going to be I think
if we we're going to use post let's say
that if we go to forward slash uh images
you can go to whatever you want right
that's up to you
we're going to essentially
do this
okay
great
of course we have to post a request and
response that is just part of the Syntax
for using Express roots and we have to
make this an async function as we are
using the awake keyword here and as we
know to use the awake keyword we have to
make it in an async function because we
need to oh wait for this to come back so
again if you don't know much about async
JavaScript that is in my course please
do check it out I'm not going to go into
it until what you do here as I'm
assuming you already have that knowledge
cool so that is my post
root at the moment what we are actually
going to do is move all of this out so
we can reuse it so I'm just going to
paste up here and of course we are going
to have to have an API key I'm just
going to get rid of that you know we
just need an acre key you can name it
whatever you want again so at the moment
this should be the only thing that's in
our express route and I'm going to stick
it in a try and cut so we're going to
try this and we're going to catch any
errors and if there are errors we're
just going to console error the error
right
so that is looking good of course we
don't really want this we want to send
this from the front end but that will we
will do that when it comes to the right
time and once we get the response all
I'm going to do is use res send and then
send the response data data I'll show
you why it's just console log the data
to see what comes back
okay so actually let's just console Vlog
the response sorry but if you actually
look in here you can kind of see the
response
okay we get the response data and this
was the object that comes back and we
just want to get the data which is this
array which holds objects which have
URLs in them but I will show you
so cool that is what happens when we
essentially make a post request to
localhost forward slash uh logo host
8000 forward slash images but don't
believe me I'm gonna show you
so let's do it on the front end what I'm
going to do is actually add an on click
to here so on
click
what do I want to happen well on click
I'm just going to get the images right
so let's define get images I'm going to
do so up here so const get images is
what I am going to call this function
and once again I'm going to use try
and catch I'm going to catch any errors
and we're just going to console error
the errors that come back and then in
here I'm going to again use a weight
because the fetch API essentially is an
async functions we need to wait for
whatever comes back to us I'm going to
save the response so I'm going to save
the response and we're using the awake
keyword here which means this needs to
be an async function as a weight cannot
live in a function that is not async and
like I said we're going to go to http
localhost as we defined eight thousand
forward slash images so that is the
route that we made we could have called
it whatever if you change it
here then of course you need to change
it here too and then we're just going to
pass through some options so let's
define those options
const options just like so and we're
going to pass through the method it's a
post method right because it's a post
method here we're going to send some
Json which we're going to replace here
so that is why it's a post request
and along with the method I'm just going
to pass through the body
um it's going to be an object okay
that's going to send a message which is
essentially going to be the value of our
input right so at the moment I'm just
gonna go with blah
make sure that is inside the object I'm
gonna have to write wrap this and do
some stringify in order to send this
whole object as Json
okay great and outside of this we also
need to pass through some headers just
to tell this that we are working with
Json so I'm going to do content
type
and then application
Jason so just like so
cool and once we get that response
I'm just going to get it to Jason but oh
this is also an Asic method so we have
to await it and we have to await the
response let's say this as maybe data
and there we go and I'm just gonna
console log the data so that's a lot
let's see if it works of course we
aren't parsing anything through we're
not even passing blur to the back end
well technically we are but that's not
always saying to the API acute BBC otter
is what we're sending to the API
so let's do it let's try this out I'm
just going to go back to my project
let's get up our console log
and then let's also not forget to get
our API key so I'm going to show you
where to get that it's just under here
we're going to view the API keys and we
can create a new one so I've just gone
ahead and created that of course this
will not be accessible to you I will
delete this so I don't know you can go
and use mine and use all my free credits
but that is how you'd create one okay
just go to account API keys and create a
new key copy it and then I'm just going
to for now
paste it
here
or in fact let's just make the EnV file
I'm just going to create a new file
let's call it dot EnV and add and then
I'm going to Define API key
equals and then put that string we don't
need to put it in uh quotations as the
string is implied and it just means I
can now use process EnV thanks to this
piece of code right here in order to
look into my EnV file and find API key
so we find it and get its value so
that's all I've done let's carry on
so yes now if I go ahead and click
generate we should be able to
communicate with our API and we're just
going to pause through a cute BBC otter
and then we should get back
two images for us so if we look in the
terminal
this is the whole response however if we
go dot data dot data like I said we're
going into the data object let's try
again I'm just going to click generate
again and let's have a look so we're
waiting for changes that will wait a
little bit longer
and there we go so we've got the data
data and here's our array of two urls
and they should be of two cute baby
otters let's have a look
okay so here is one it is a cute baby
otter wonderful so that is working and
that's what we are sending back to the
front end so that we can use it here's
we can now map these two images onto
here so let's do that next
back on the front end let's actually
just make this a bit smaller now or
actually just yeah get rid of that
completely I'm going to use States so
let's go ahead and import the use State
hook import use State primary act so we
can save stuff to the state of this
component so I'm going to do const let's
maybe save the what should we call this
I guess images right that's what they
are images set images
use State and let's start off with null
and now once we get back that data so
the responses data data which is what
we're console logging out here so it's
an array of two objects I'm going to use
set images to just set that data right
so now we're going to have images
and we can now get the images to show up
so all I'm going to do is in the image
section let's open this up and then if
essentially images exist I want to map
each image we're going to have to get
the index as well because we're going to
have to essentially map that onto a key
so let's get each image
and it's getting index we're not really
going to use this I'm just going to
underscore it
and then I am going to create an image
element like I said this is very simple
so you know if you want to build this
out and create components please do this
is just to get us used to using the open
AI API let's go ahead and add in key so
I'm going to use index and now I'm going
to add the source and the sources of
this is going to be the image well if we
look at what's coming back to us here is
my first item it's an object so we're
going to use dot notation to get the URL
so I'm going to dot URL and add some
alternative text I'm just going to do
generated image of and then I guess
whatever my prompt was right so actually
what we can do is just put in the value
so the value is going to be my prompt
which of course we haven't written yet
but I think that's kind of a cool way to
do it
right because we need this for the
visually impaired
so now maybe let's just get the value so
I'm just going to save the value of the
input up here to const Value set value
and then let's do use State null to
start off with however we can set the
value on the input change so on change
of this
I'm just going to get to the event
and then set value e Target value so
that is how you would change the value
of the input we can also display it in
here just by passing through the value
okay so now if we have a look if I'm
just going to console log this out to up
here console
log value
right so at the moment value is null but
if I change this it changes here and
that's what we can send over
when we make a request
cool
so we are saving the value and then
we're just showing it here we're also
going to save it here of the generated
image once we have the images back
so now that we are mapping that on let's
have a look so
let's have a look here
why is it shouting at us
okay so we want to essentially map those
images right onto images and that's what
we are doing however let's also make
sure that each image that lives inside
the element of the images section so
let's grab the images section again
okay and down here I'm going to grab the
image section and just make sure that
it's where it does span 100 of the
parent I'm also just going to make sure
that everything wraps over each other so
I'm going to initialize flexbox for that
I'm also then going to make sure that it
wraps over writes I'm going to do Flex
wrap wrap
and then I'm also going to align items
stretch so they stretch out and I'm
going to justify content space between
so that the images kind of stretch okay
but of course we won't really be able to
see anything until we get the images so
let's just say that any image that is
inside the image section is going to
let's give each one a margin of one
pixel so there's space out from each
other let's also give them a Min width
of 250 pixels but then also a Max width
of
um let's see 33 of the parrot I'm also
going to use flex grow to make sure that
they stretch out
okay cool what I'm also going to do so
at the moment we really won't see much
let's maybe generate this again and wait
for those little orders to come back so
let's wait even though it'll be hard to
see with two so maybe let's just change
the amount that come back sorry about
that let's just change it to 10 baby
otters
and let's try again so generate
okay and now we're gonna have 10 we're
going to see what it looks like when
there's lots of images populating our
app because it does take a while for
this API to do its thing we are working
with uh images as well so it will take
some time in order for that to show up
okay
so there we go here's our 10 images and
here's our 10 baby orders how cute is
that we should probably space it out
from the top but we will deal with that
later I just want to show you that this
is what it looks like and then we can
even add media queries so I can add a
media query
let's go back here and I'm just going to
do at media Max
width let's go with five five six pixels
and then I'm just going to say that any
image that lives inside the image
section is actually just going to have a
Max width of a hundred percent so it's
going to essentially take up the whole
Space if I get to a certain point
cool right okay
what else do I want to do
maybe let's also get the search section
so search section and assign a height I
don't know 300 pixels whatever you think
will look nice so I think that looks
okay we can make it smaller like
honestly this is just styling that you
can get way too wrapped up in when we
just want to learn how to use the open
EI but you know I think that looks
better
so now let's actually get to passing the
value through so we don't just get
otters I'm going to show you how to do
that next so let's go back to the app we
are setting the value here right so now
all I'm going to do is get that value
and replace it with blur
so that we go making sure that is code
and that now that means that's going to
be passed over with our options so other
on the server that gets sent over and
it's part of the body right so if we
look at here it's gonna be part of the
request body message and this is an
object so we use dot notation so I can
just go with using request body
message
to get whatever that value is so this
right here make sure to wrap it in
adjacent stringify and make sure that is
here in order for that to work but
essentially now let's check this out so
let's go back here
uh what should we do this time I'm just
gonna refresh this for now let's go with
oh let's do surprise me right let's hook
up the surprise me so let's go back here
and on
click of the surprise me so on click
I'm gonna write a function called
surprise me and let's define it so let's
grab this
const surprise me equals and then all
I'm going to do is essentially
set the value so set value
to be well I'm gonna get the surprise me
options or let's maybe yeah let's get
the const Run dumb value from the array
I'm going to get the surprise options
and I'm going to pass through into them
to get back a random number from 0 to 2
as that is index 0 1 and 2 and to do
that I'm going to essentially use math
run done and call it but multiply it by
the surprise options
length Okay and then round that number
down because that will give this gives
me back a random number from zero to
just under one and if I multiply it by
the length it would be from zero to just
under three but of course three agents
exist we want to round it down to two so
that's why I pass it Through Math
okay so that is how you would get a
random value and we just pass it through
into set value
so now if I click on here
how cool is that let's go with a Matisse
star shark on a telephone and generate
and wait for that to do its thing
and we get our ten sharks this is cool
and here they are here are 10 randomly
generated sharks I love them they're
pretty awesome of course it will take a
while for the images to download but I
mean this is like super Arty and I'm
really into it
of course we can write our own thing
so we can do
a cool ice cream
and generates
you will see how that value is updating
every time we type it but that value
will only be sent once we hit to
generate as well so that is something
that you should know
okay and then that's replacing the
images here of cool ice creams okay of
course we have to wait a little bit for
that to completely re replaced one thing
we can do is when we click the surprise
me we actually set the images
to be null
first as well as I think when we get the
images again let's just reset that and
actually Also let's say that if value
equals null right so if we just click it
but there's no value then we're going to
set an error message and that error
message is going to say error must
have a search term right okay and I'm
going to return out of this because you
don't want to do anything else so let's
set error messages const error set
error
use State we're going to have a null to
start I'm going to set the error and if
we do have an error I'm just going to
display it down here I'm actually just
going to maybe display it I think let's
go with
just outside of the input container down
here I'm just going to show the error if
one exists so maybe let's wrap it if
error exists then we show the P element
with the error so no P element exists
and SN is an error present
okay so now let's check it out
a cool hat and generate and wait for
that to do its thing
and we get some cool hats and if we
click surprise me it'll clear those
images so that we can start fresh and we
can generate or surprise me prompt okay
and again it's same if we want to remove
this is some more
cool hats and generate it will clear
those images so we can start fresh so
that is a much better approach
right so generate 10 images they look
pretty cool I think now I'm really
excited to show you this next part as
this well this took me a while to figure
out so I'm excited to share my result
with you and it's all about generating
variations of an image that already
exists so this was interesting because
we're gonna have to figure out how to
upload existing images onto here not
just write prompts and use the images
create image variation endpoint for this
part so let's do it so first off I'm
just going to go ahead and add an input
that will allow us to do this so I'm
going to show you how I would personally
solve this part I would so this is the
input we don't want to do it in the
input container let's perhaps do it
outside of the input container
so what I'm going to do is actually
create a p element outside of the input
container so just make sure that is
finished here and here what I'm going to
do maybe let's just format this a little
bit better while we are at it okay so
there we go I'm going to use a p element
and I'm just going to write or
uh let's actually also give this a class
name so we can figure out I'm going to
go the class name of a extra info
so just like that we're going to have or
and then I'm going to actually create a
span but this span so maybe let's put
this on a new line This span is going to
hold a bunch of stuff it's going to hold
a label okay and the label is going to
say upload an image
okay it's all part of one sentence so
that's going to say upload an image and
this label is four
so let's use html4
this is four
something with the idea of files what's
going to be an input
okay with the ID of files so that's how
you would link them up so if we click on
the label it will affect this input I'm
going to show you what I mean and here
this is going to have a files but it's
also going to have an accept and it's
going to accept all types of image so
I'm just going to go with image
like this
um and it's going to take the type of
file so at the moment if I look at this
it will
look like that
or upload an image but I want to hide
this part okay and I want what I want to
happen is if I click on upload an image
then it chooses an image for me without
actually showing this part so let's add
hidden
to this to hide that
okay
and so all uploads an image and then I'm
just going to put some more text and
that is going to say
to edit
okay so there we go maybe we just needs
a space
to edit here
so I'm going to put a space there
press space there ID match otherwise
that will not work and it just means
that now if I go ahead and click on here
that should open that up okay and now
what I'm gonna do is actually grab this
class of extra info and I'm just going
to make sure that the text is centered
so extra info and then I'm going to go
with text align Center
so there we go that is now done however
why is this not centered let's have a
look back here
class name
and wonderful so now we can upload new
images this is great part one is kind of
done now let's move on
so I'm going to go back in here
and what do I want to do well if we
click on this I essentially so if we
click on this whole thing I want a modal
to pop up and a bunch of other stuff so
I'm going to do on change of this input
so if we select something from the files
make sure to have type file on this
input in order for this input to look
the way it does I'm going to upload an
image so we can view it so let's define
upload image so I'm going to maybe do so
here so let's get rid of that const
upload image equals and then we're going
to get whatever so we're going to hop us
to e because we're going to get the
e-target file so the files we uploaded
so if I just console log e Target
files
I'm going to show you what happens so
back in here let's upload this test
image
okay this is what comes back and we just
want to get that first item so this it's
a file called test.png so there it is
so we could just go into this and get
the first item from it because we just
want one
so there will always just be one because
we chose to get a singular file so there
we go
so now that we have that file what I
want to do is create a form so we can
send over the whole form so I'm going to
do const form data equals and I'm going
to create a new form
data
Constructor so now to append to this
existing form data I'm going to use
append and we are going to essentially
append a file so the property file along
with the e-target file so we're sending
that over with the form data we need to
send that over the form data in order
for this to work you can of course send
other stuff too that is totally up to
you then what I'm going to do is set the
selected image so set selected
image and I'm just going to
pass through this so we know what the
selected image is and of course we need
to save that to state so let's do const
selected image set selected
image
and then we're going to use State no
because it's going to be nothing at
first we are just essentially storing
whatever image we select to this
component okay great
and now all I'm going to do is just send
that image to my back end so what I am
going to do is use try and catch to
catch any errors
and I'm going to use the await fetch so
we need to make this an async function
and we're going to define a root on the
back end
so once again let's do app it's going to
be a post and we're going to post to
let's go to upload and essentially
what's going to happen here is I'm
literally just going to send this image
here and save it to my server
so it's essentially going to show up
here okay or we can put it in the public
folder we can put it wherever that is up
to us
so let's also pass through the request
and the response
and what else do we need to pass through
from the front end
so yes let's go ahead and use this
however we have defined this endpoint as
upload this time and it also pass
through the options so just as above and
let's define our options so whoops this
is meant to be up here and we're just
going to console error error
so that's the final options as I said
const options equals it's going to be an
object of course we have to wait for
this response
and the options that we're going to pass
through where we're going to pass
through the methods which is a post
method we're also going to pass through
the body which is just going to be our
form data that we have and we appended
the file to
and then I'm just going to console log
the response so we can see it but of
course we need to get that response
first and get it to Json
call it an await this
and let's say this as
data okay so then we just cancel all the
data again
cool
so let's see if we can send that image
to the server and on the server there's
a few things we need to do we're
actually going to now have to require
those packages
so let's move that up here and then up
here I'm going to FS require
FS
we're also going to require a package
called multi which is going to help us
save those files so require
motor
so once we have those two we are now
ready to start essentially adding files
to our repository by sending them to our
backend so all I'm going to do I did get
this code from the documentation so
we're going to use upload and upload
we're going to Define up here so maybe
actually let's define it here where we
Define a bunch of other stuff
I'm just going to make this smaller for
now
I'm going to do const upload equals I'm
going to use a multi and we're just
going to pass through
storage
and storage we're going to also Define
and we're going to be working with
single files right so we'll do is file
single
okay so let's define storage now con
storage and here's where we're going to
essentially Define where we want to
store those files so motor disk storage
I'm going to open this up I'm going to
pause to an object I'm going to define
the destination the destination here is
the syntax again so again I've just
taken this from the documentation
I'm going to do CB and then we're going
to save it to the public directory in
this project so they're going to be
saved in here okay so that's what I've
written if you want to just be saved you
know like in the root of your project
you could do
this right so that is what you can do as
well so I've just defined where I want
to save these files
next I'm also going to Define how I want
the file name to look so again I could
do request
file CB
and now I'm going to do CB
now and then I'm just going to use
today's date and call it so I get
today's date plus I'm going to use this
little line This Dash plus the original
file name so file a read General
name okay because if we console log file
here you will see the whole file object
so console log file I'm going to show
you what this looks like let's go ahead
and just put in a string of file as well
so you can see a lot better
[Music]
so I believe that's it here are the
things you will need
so those two right here
so now we can use upload that we defined
up there and again request response and
it's plus two errors
and
this code I literally just got from the
documentation
so if there's an error just send back
the errors otherwise I'm just going to
console log the request
file okay
great
so now let's check it out I'm going to
go back here and let's upload an image
I'm going to just go with this test or
test
okay so that's the file and that should
have triggered my request so if I look
in here and let's look at the terminal
okay I believe that should have worked I
can see that we here's the date right
and here's the dash and here's my
original file name so that as well
that's the whole file and essentially I
did file dot original name to get the
original name right so that's what we
did
file original name so I've Consolidated
the file I've looked in the object and
got the file name and appended it with
the date now to create
let's look in public this file right
here so how cool is that we've just
saved a PNG file into our project okay
really cool and like I said if I just
did this and then let's try again so
let's upload maybe let's just pick the
same file taste.com
dot PNG and now if we look in here
and let's just wait a bit Tada you will
see that file is now in here not in the
public directory but I do want them to
be saved in the public directory so I'm
just going to put that back
so I'm just going to delete these for
now so we can carry on but essentially
we are saving files into our project how
cool is that
wonderful
so something I didn't say and this is
kind of important is that the images
must be a certain size so the three size
that we saw at the beginning uh one was
256 by 256 so make sure your image is
that size in order for it to work
correctly or the other two that you saw
now of course this is a very basic
tutorial on how to use the open AI API
it would be cool for you to be able to
crop images in here but it's outside of
the scope of this project so just make
sure to upload the correct files if you
want to build this out correctly but we
compute a few Stoppers so for example
let's put our model that only allows you
to upload certain size images next
so again I just did that and here is my
image it's got the date as well as what
I call the image which is 256x256 PNG
which is the size of that image so we
are saving these images back here the
next thing we need to do is actually
send them over to our back end but
before we do that I actually want to
build a modal first so we can see the
image and its preview so what I'm going
to do is in the source directory I'm
going to create a new
directory called components and we're
going to build a modal so components
and in here I'm going to create a new
file I'm going to call it modal Js
and we are just going to build out that
component okay so we're going to add
that
so let's do it I'm going to do const
module
equals
and then we're going to return some jsx
so at the moment it's going to be a div
I'm going to export defaults
modal so just like that
okay and what do we want our modal to
look like well I'm just going to give
this the class name
of the model
like so and in here I'm going to have a
div and we're going to actually use
state in order to open and close the
modal so let's import use state
primary act because we're going to have
to save the uh I guess
I guess a few things well we're gonna
have to save any error messages so let's
just do error set error these errors are
contained to this component unlike on
the app
use State we're going to start off with
no so just like so
and actually do we want to control well
I'd actually like to control a few more
things based on whether the model is
open or not on the app so we're going to
pass through the set module from the app
itself
so let's go ahead and do that const
model
open set
modal open
use state I'm going to start off with
being false of course and it is not open
so cool I think maybe let's start off
with just importing this mode also
import modal
from
components modal so now I can just use
that module down here and where shall we
put it I guess it doesn't really matter
too much because we're going to Overlay
it with an overlay
so by that I mean I'm going to create a
div and in here I'm just going to put in
the modal like so and I'm going to give
this the class name of
overlay but I only want to show this if
open modal is true
so we're going to wrap all of that in
open Mojo So
sorry Moodle open it was not open modal
so
modal open and I'm just going to hard
this to be true for now so we can see
what it looks like
so at the moment of course it doesn't
look like anything because we haven't
set up the modal so let's do that next
so I'm going to go back in here
and what else we want in our modal
well I'm just going to have a div that
says X so we can close it by the X and
on click of this I essentially just want
to close this mode also I'm going to
close modal I'm going to define the
function here
so let's do const close modal
equals I want a few things to happen
though and what I want to happen is I
want to use set modal to be
false so set modal open sorry
to be false right which means we need to
pass that through so let's go back here
I'm going to use set mode will open I'm
going to pass it through into the modal
so we can use it which means we need to
destructure that prop here destructure
it so we can use it there one other
thing I want to do is set selected image
to null as well right because we have if
we have a selected image we don't want
any more if we close the modal so that
is something else that we're going to
have to pass through
into
the modal here so set selected image
and then let's destructure it so we can
use it there great so that is what
happens if we click on the X next I'm
going to have a div
and this is going to be for my image so
I'm just going to use the image element
and let's give this the class name of
image container just like so
okay
and the image container is going to hold
our image which should only really show
if a selected image exists
so the electric image exists then we
want to show this right and as the
source of this we want to get that
selected image
and show it however
to selected image not set selected image
there's a few things we need to do first
off we need to pass this through into
the modal right so whatever we set here
as a selected image we are passing
through into the modal and now we need
to destructurate him
so actually if I console log what this
looks like
uh selected image
and what is wrong here so we need to
wrap this okay so selected image exists
then we show the image with the selected
image as well as some alternative text
let's go with
uploaded image
however it will not work because so
let's go ahead and do this let's go with
this image right here open
our selected image will look like this
because at the moment it looks like an
object like this we need to pass it
through URL I'm going to show you
URL create object URL and then pass that
through okay so we're passing that whole
thing into here so now we can see it and
great so once again to upload an image
and then here is our module let's also
put in a button so that we can generate
from that selected image so after the
image container
um I'm going to just put a button
that says
generate okay and let's solve this up so
first off what I'm going to do is just
grab the well actually let's grab the
overlay first so let's grab the class
name of overlay
just down here and I'm going to position
this so I'm going to give this position
absolute
top zero left zero I'm going to make it
take up the whole width so 100 you put
width and the whole height so 100
viewport height and give it a background
color a background color that is
transparent so we can still kind of see
everything behind it so let's go with
black and 0.150 pieces too so that is
what it's going to look like I'm also
going to make sure we can't scroll by
giving overflow it's in okay so that we
go that is what it looks like at the
moment and we can't scroll thanks to
overflow hidden
next I'm just going to Center everything
so first off I think let's initialize
flexbox now I'm going to use justify
content Center
and align items Center as well okay so
there we go and the last thing I'm going
to do is just make sure it's in front of
everything by giving it Zend index of
10. okay just making sure that it's 100
in front of everything so that is what
it looks like and if we close it here it
shuts the model let's try again let's
open up a new image
okay that does not work I wonder why
let's just refresh
close that
uh we are
overriding this so let's make this back
to be false again so we start off with
the model being closed
so let's go back to here
and scroll down as soon as we save that
form data we're also going to set modal
open to be true okay
great
so let's try again
upload amazing and now let's start this
up a little bit further
so all I'm going to do is now back on
the index CSS after the overlay I'm
going to get the element with the class
of module I'm going to position
it's relative
I'm also going to make sure that the Z
index is the highest so let's just go
with 100 to be safe let's make the
background color white
and now I'm going to give a padding of
10 pixels a border radius to round It
Off
of 10 pixels
let's go with display flex and I'm going
to go with flex Direction
column to make sure that everything's
stacked over each other so at the moment
it should like this and now let's style
the button too so let's grab the
button that lives inside the module
and I'm just going to make sure that the
width is a hundred percent
the padding is 20 pixels and border
is going to be none and now if we
actually make it active so if we click
on it
I'm just going to change the background
color so let's go background color and
then f a f a f c
so that is much more I think what it
should look like I'm happier with
that
cool I'm just going to change the X text
icon
so choose one of these instead just to
make it look that little bit cooler so
let's go with maybe this one instead
on the modal I'm just going to replace
that like so
okay so that is better
okay so let's try again
great
let's also maybe make this background
color white as well
so I'm happy with how this is looking
I'm just going to maybe go with cursor
pointer for this just to make it obvious
that we can click on this the next thing
we want to do is generate images based
on this one right however we want to set
some error messages just to let us know
that this image is not the right size so
let's do that next so on the model
itself we are going to say the errors
and when do we want an error to happen
well I think let's also have another
button here
as we want to check the size first so
when we click generate
we don't actually want to generate we're
going to add on click to check size
okay so let's define this check size
const check size equals
and then I am going to essentially use
ref so let's import use ref
from react
so this means I need to initialize it
constraph equals use ref and then I'm
just going to pass through no and we're
going to do so on the image itself so
ref equals ref this is essentially the
component that we care about because
we're going to get its size
okay and to do that when we click check
size we're essentially going to say that
if ref current width we're getting its
current width and if it equals 256 and
if ref current Heights
equals 256 then we're fine then we're
good to go then we can essentially write
a function to generate variations
okay we're good to go on that otherwise
if it is not well then we've got an
error and I'm just going to use set
Arrow to set the error of error
choose two five six by two five six
image just to be safe
okay so now we're setting an error and
essentially one we want to display that
error right so let's say that if error
exists
then we want to or actually let's have
some text here anyway so I'm just going
to have as a default some text that says
uh
image
must be two five six by two five six
however if an error exists I want to
override that so if Eric does show that
otherwise show
that string
okay
cool make sure it's in Kali braces so it
gets picked up as a code
okay so now if that is essentially no
error then show this button whether if
there is an error
then we show this button instead
so and and
that says close this and try again
okay so and then on click of this we can
just you guessed it close the modal so
we're using that function close
wonderful
so now let's try upload something else
right so upload an image I'm going to go
with this super long one
oh it's very large
um maybe let's actually
control how these images are viewed
right so I'm also going to say that the
image container
that holds our image
is going to have a height of 256 pixels
let's put that inside
and a whip of two five six pixels
and then I'm also just going to do
overflow hidden so it's really obvious
that the image is too big because it
will look like this or look or cut off
and if I hit generate it says error
choose 256 by 256 image close this and
try again how cool is that I'm pretty
proud with what I've built here and then
we can choose an image that is two five
six by two five six pixels and we can
generate
okay so cool let's actually work on
writing the generate function next
so we've defined a generate function
here generate variations however
we haven't actually done it here so
let's go ahead and do that
so for this what I'm going to do is go
back to the server and Define a root so
let's do it so as we saw that file
console request file is being saved here
this is the whole file essentially right
that's how we're getting the file name
from it we need to get its path okay so
I'm going to get it dot path and I'm
actually going to save this as something
so I'm going to save it up here maybe
yep sure so let's go with let file path
at the moment it'll be nothing but as
soon as we have a value for it so as
soon as this runs I want to get request
file path and save it to file path so
that we can use it in our next
root which is going to be a post request
and let's define this let's call this
variations you can call it whatever you
want and we're going to pass through the
request and the response and this again
let's have a look at open AI for this so
let's look at the documentation well
we're obviously going to make a request
to this URL so we can just take all of
this so copy it make sure your node.js
and copy all of this this will create an
image variation let's go back in here
and let's go ahead and use try and catch
again so try
I'm going to paste that in like so we
don't need this as we've already done
that and we've already defined open AI
so we just need the response we have the
await keyword there so we need to make
this an async function and now let's
catch any errors so try and then catch
error
console error
the error okay so that's what we have
done and now we can get that response
and we're just going to send
res send response and the object so
response data comes back as this so we
need to do dot data again so response
data data is what we need to write great
however we know that we don't want
to pass through this string what we want
to pass through is the file path that we
saved up here right so the file path
that we got here when we upload the
images we go the file path which is
essentially the file part to any one of
these files the last one we uploaded
and then we're just going to pass that
through like so okay so wonderful and we
are hot coding this let's get about 10
images all at this size and once that
comes back to us so back in here
let's get the response so let's actually
hook this up to our front end next so
cons generate
variations equals
and then all I'm going to do is try and
catch again so try
and let's
catch any errors so catch
error
console error error and we are going to
try what we're going to use a weight
Fetch and we're going to go to
localhost 8000 for variations this time
right so make sure that is in a string
and then we're going to also pass
through the options which we are going
to Define so const options we know this
is a post request
so options
method
string of
posts and we actually don't need
anything else so let's just get the
response of the super once
response and then we're going to get the
response don't forget to make this an
async function
let's get the response get to Json and
this is uh oh again async so use the
awake keyword and let's get its data and
then I'm just going to essentially
console of the data so we can see it but
I know it's going to be an array of
images so I can just set images to be
the data and once we are done I'm just
going to set error as null if there are
any errors
and I'm also going to set modal open as
false so it shuts the modal okay great
so when do we want to generate these
variations well we want to generate them
after we check the size right so I'm
going to go back to the modal here I'm
going to pass through generate
variations
just like so you know let's maybe put
these on a new line so you can see
everything that we're passing through
into this wonderful modal so generate a
very
Sean's I've obviously misspelt it
generate variation
okay so that's better and now on the
modal let's just copy it so I don't make
any spelling mistakes
let's pass it through here as well and
now let's essentially
call it okay before we move on I am just
going to also just set the images to
null so we can start fresh and if
selected image equals null okay when we
try to generate the images I just want a
certain error message and just say that
no image has been selected so that we
can't generate anything you can pass
through whatever you want this is the
string that I am choosing to pass
through so that it shows up and finally
we're just going to close the modal so
I'm just going to use set modal and pass
through false and return out of this so
that we don't go to the next thing and
lastly just so that we don't have any
issues when uploading an image again so
the same image again I'm just gonna
clear the files we selected and we can
do so so right after we set the selected
image I'm just going to get a Target
value and set it to no
great
so let's give it a whirl
so
let's go back here
upload an image let's upload this image
that meets the requirements and generate
and now let's wait so once I've done
this thing it should shut this Moodle it
should get rid of any error messages and
it should show 10 variations of this
image that I uploaded which is pretty
awesome let's be honest
and there we go we can see those 10
images and those 10 URLs and 10
variations of me how cool is that I mean
some of them are like super scary but
you know at least we have managed to do
it I really enjoyed showing you this
tutorial it was really fun to make it's
been the funnest one I made in a while
so I hope you had fun thanks so much
again and don't forget to clean up your
code get rid of you know like we use RGB
and hex and we also used variations of
different quilt marks and we haven't
formatted the code so please go ahead
and do that and take this project make
your own you know style it up there's so
much to do it is
yours and then we can clear again
okay everyone in this project we're
going to be using chat GPT 4 so the gpt4
model in order to create this SQL
generator so this is going to be cool
we're going to be able to save our
messages up here in the chat and then
we're going to display the final outcome
so the SQL query we asked it to write in
the little code section below so that's
what we're going to be doing as you can
see here we can scroll through all our
previous chats and we can also clear the
chat okay so I hope you're excited we're
going to be building this in typescript
for the front end and node.js for the
back end as well as the open AI API
using the chat completions endpoint
okay so let's do it let's create a SQL
generator in typescript with a node.js
backend so all I'm going to do is select
a new project and this is going to be a
typescript project so I can go ahead and
click here and make it a typescript
project by selecting this right here so
that's all I'm going to do and let's go
ahead and call this type script SQL
generator and hit create
okay so that will essentially spin up a
typescript project for me
so let's just go ahead and wait for that
to do its thing if you're not using
webstorm all you have to do is get your
terminal up
find a directory you want to work in so
I'm going to go into some projects and
use npx create react app then whatever
you want to call your app and then dash
dash template
typescript so that's all you'd have to
do and hit enter however I'm not going
to do that because I've done it this way
so there we go happy hacking and now
you'll see all the files that I need
we've got the TS config.json or the
package.json and then we've got the
source directory I'm just going to go
ahead and delete what we don't want so
we're not going to write any tests or
anything like that so I'm going to
delete these two so this app CSS and the
test file then I'm going to also delete
the logo
so let's go ahead and delete that
so just go ahead and click delete and
then we're going to also delete the
report of vitals and setup tests as
we're not going to need those either so
delete those two there we go
okay
great
so let's now have a look in my app TSX
I'm just going to pretty much delete
everything so that we can start fresh so
there we go just delete all that we
don't really even need to import react
let's change this to a functional
expression just because that is my
preference so just like so and then I'm
just going to change the class name so
an export default that component great
I'm going to delete everything from the
CSS file and in here I'm just going to
delete anything to do with testing or
reporting with vitals and I'm also going
to delete these semicolons just because
I don't really like using them at well
okay great so this is what my index TSX
will look like this is on my app TSX
will look like and this is what my index
CSS will look like the next thing I'm
going to do is actually first off let's
just create the UI first this shouldn't
take too long I'm just going to create a
few components so I'm going to create a
directory
to keep all my components in
and in here the components I'm going to
create are going to be a code display
okay so we can see our code
don't forget to use the extension TSX as
this is going to be a typescript file
with jsx and then I'm also going to
create a messages display they'll hold
all our messages so messages plural
dot TSX again because we're going to
have jsx in here so just add that and
then I'm going to create a new file I'm
going to do this it's going to be for
one individual message the message
display.ts
yes great so there we go we've got three
components and I'm literally just going
to copy this and I'm going to paste that
in here like so so enter the code
display let's change this to say code
display and then let's
export that code display and I'm just
going to change this to say code display
let's do the same for messages
displacements and copy all that click on
messages display and this time I'm just
going to change this view messages
plural
message is plural so that's what the
component is called and I'm going to
call this messages plural display and
finally for the message display well
this is easy I'm just going to make it
not plural so just sing on those three
things
right
so we've just created our three
components let's go ahead
and to the project
so on the app
well I'm going to have to have a
messages displayed first because we want
all the messages to display up here so
that has been imported for me
automatically so thank you very much
we're going into the components
directory and getting the messages
display component we're going to pass
stuff through interior but for now let's
move on I'm also going to have an input
okay because we're going to have to want
to you know send queries over so there
is my input it's going to take a value
and it's going to have an unchanged but
we'll do that when the time comes next
I'm just going to have the code display
so there we go let's see if that's
automagically inserted and it is
great and one last thing I'm going to
have is just a div and this is going to
be for our buttons so I'm going to give
this the class name of
button container so you can hold up
buttons we're gonna have two in here so
I'm gonna have one button let's give
this the ID of
get
query because it's gonna help us get
queries so get query just like so and
then another button this one's going to
be for clearing the chat so I'm just
going to paste that in and let's give
this the ID of clear chat so you can
start it up differently and let's just
change the text weekly
great
so that is what it should look like now
the messages display so the plural we're
going to actually have a message display
in here so we're going to import message
display from message display as we're in
the same place we're here right so we
just imported from here so we don't need
to go into the components or anything
like that and I'm actually going to map
all the different messages onto one
individual message display
now let's do a little bit of styling so
first off what I'm going to do
is say that everything in here so
everything in my entire project is going
to have the same font family I'm going
to go with verdana and then as a backup
let's just have Tahoma and then let's
have Suns serve good old trusty Sans
serve and the text is going to be RGB
this is the color I picked out just this
is your very dark gray you could almost
mistake it for black
next I'm going to say that any P element
as well as the input are going to have a
specific font size so I want the birds
to have the font size
of 16 pixels
so that's what I have done
next I'm going to grab the whole body
and I'm just going to get rid of any
default margin and padding just to make
sure that there's no lines around our
document so margin zero padding zero
okay and now I'm gonna Center the app so
for this I'm going to use display Flex
initialize flexbox which means that now
I can use justify content Center to
Center everything from left to right and
now I can also use align items Center to
send everything to top to bottom so on
the cross axis but for this to work I
need to give this a height so I'm going
to go with 100 viewport height of the
browser and let's just go ahead and give
this a background color as well I'm
going to go with uh far far far and we
should probably change this to be RGB
right because
I think
let's try keep everything consistent so
250 250 250 RGB 250
250 250. great
and now let's actually grab the app
itself so we're going to use dot
notation to get that class name
and the app is going to be 80 of the
viewport height of the browser and 80 of
the viewport width I'm also going to
give it a background color this time
it's going to be white so 255 2x5 255.
okay let's also round it off a little
bit just slightly let's go 10 pixels
just to not make it a harsh square and
let's also add a box Shadow now my box
Shadow I'm going to start off with being
black but transparent so A is for
transparency there we go black I'm going
to put 0 1.6 for the transparency and
we're going to also put 0x axis 1 pixel
y axis and four pixels uh blur okay
so there we go
so at the moment let's see what this
looks like in fact let's go ahead and
look at our start script so if I do NPR
on start it will start this however I
actually want to add another script to
start a back end so start back and let's
just make this a little bit bigger which
means that let's change this to restart
front now to start my back end in a
typescript project if I want to use
um type modules I'm going to have to do
TS node
and then esm
and then we're going to read the index
TS file which we haven't made as a TS
file because we're not going to have any
jsx in there okay so make sure to have
this if you want to add types which I am
going to do up here so all I'm going to
do is write
module so that we can import
modules in our index TS file and by
import I mean we're not going to use
require anymore
so that's two things you need to do you
need to do this
and you need to do that and we also need
to import this package so I'm just going
to go ahead and do that let's do so and
here making sure you are in the project
and PMI TS node so that's going to go
ahead and install and while I'm here I'm
also going to install cause and express
as I know I'm going to need those two
so great that is now done
so now let's actually get to creating
this index TS file which is going to
essentially be our backend so all I'm
going to do is create a new file called
index TS so there we go just make sure
it's there in your projects on the same
level as the package just
so now to start my front end
front
and I'm just going to grab this and in
the terminal I'm going to do npm Run
start front end and that should start at
my front end localhost 3000 there we go
that's what we've built so far I'm just
going to inspect this from now just so
we can see a little bit more of what is
going on
great let's carry on starting a little
bit before we start adding the actual
meteor code
so let's go back here I'm just going to
minimize this for now
get rid of that just get rid of that for
now let's style our code display so I'm
just going to grab the code display
just down here like so
and I'm going to give it a whip of 96 of
the parent a margin of 2 to make up for
the 100 taken from there and a height of
let's just go 46 let's see how that
looks I'm also going to round it off so
let's give it aboard a radius of 8
pixels this time
and let's give it a background color so
again I picked out this background color
I'm going to go with RGB three four
three four three four
okay great and I'm also just going to
hide any overflow so overflow header so
at the moment it will look like this
let's also add that little
um I guess uh header with the three dots
just to make it look more like a little
code display
so for that what I'm going to do is well
I'm gonna go to the code display so just
here and I'm going to add a div and this
is going to hold some buttons so let's
go ahead and give the class name of
buttons making sure to spell it
correctly of course and let's add three
buttons so this div is going to have the
class name of
first
button or let's actually give them all
the class name of the button that'll
make more sense so this is a button this
is a button this is a button this is
going to be the first so that's a
separate class name right this is going
to be middle and this is going to be the
last you can do fast second third it's
up to you
great so that's what we're going to have
so those are the buttons
in my code display and after the buttons
I'm also going to have another div and
this I'm going to actually style as well
I'm going to
give this code output
and we're gonna want to put our
text essentially it's going to be a
string in here
okay so there we go I think we are done
with this for now I'm just going to
minimize this let's pick out the buttons
first and then the buttons and so on
so let's just get rid of that I'm going
to minimize this too
and let's get the buttons class name so
just like so
now my buttons I want this to span the
whole way I'm also going to hard code a
height right because we don't really
want this to change and let's give it a
background color of a slightly lighter
gray
so there we go and I want to make sure
that all the buttons inside of it appear
next to each other and for that I'm just
going to use display flex and I also
want them to align uh in the center from
top to bottom so I'm going to use align
items Center because we're going on the
cross axis next I also well actually
let's just I also want the buttons or
anything inside the buttons display to
start
a little bit from the left so I'm going
to give padding left five pixels
great so now let's pick out each button
each button I'm just going to actually
make a button so a circle essentially
I'm going to make sure it's 15 pixels
which means that the width needs to be
15 pixels because we're making a circle
let's go ahead and do border radius 50
and then let's also space all these out
so margin
uh let's go four pixels so there's four
pixel space around each one
now of course if I was just to give this
a background color of
let's go with red just like that and
have a look we get three little buttons
but I've also given a separate class
names as you will see here first middle
and last so I'm gonna now change the
color by grabbing these class names
so I can actually grab the element with
the class name button and if it also has
the class name or first you'll see
there's a joint I can choose a different
background color I'm going to go with
RGB two five five nine six eight six and
then let's do
button middle it was and it changes to
be
one eight nine
four five and then let's do button
last and change this to be
three eight
two or one so
four
so there we go this is looking great
let's work on the messages display next
so all I'm going to do is get the
messages plural display so let's grab
that and I'm going to make sure that
essentially it's the same width as the
code display and let's also look yeah
let's grab all that just so it's the
same size exactly and I'm also just
going to add a Scrolls if there's more
than messages that fit I'm going to go
overflow only on the y-axis and I'm
going to do scroll so the little scroll
should appear
okay
wonderful now let's style each actual
message so each message is essentially
just going to be kind of a square with
rounded off edges I want to take up a
hundred percent of the parent so 100
I want everything inside of it to appear
from left to right because I think we
should have
you know a p element in here that will
show you the user and then another P
element that will actually show you the
message itself and actually maybe a
third one too that's just going to show
some kind of icon so I want these to
appear next to each other right so let's
also give this a closing P tag
that we go so that's one two
three and if I want them to appear next
to each other that's why we did display
Flex
great let's also round this off a bit
let's do border radius five pixels and
I'm also going to do box sizing
border box to make sure everything's on
the inside and then I'm also just going
to change the background color to be the
same background color as I think the
body let's go ahead and do that
so I'm just going to paste in that like
so and now I'm also going to space out
each message from each other's user
message block buy five pixels from the
top and bottom and zero from the left
and right so that is what that will do
great
so if we look in here now that is what a
message will look like and if I have
many of these so let's go
and here let's just pretend that we have
loads and loads of messages all of a
sudden
okay is that enough okay you will see
it's scrolling but I'd actually quite
like the scroll to always be there just
because I want to be really obvious that
we can scroll and to do that what I'm
going to do is back in here I'm just
going to add this little piece of code
so I've just taken this from the
internet with the messages display
okay and that will allow me to do that
it will be exactly the same visually
apart from it will always be that now
great
so let's carry on I'm actually going to
give the message display let's give this
the ID of Icon just so we can pan it out
a little bit so I'm going to grab this
and look for essentially any P element
that also has the ID of Icon and I'm
going to give the padding of this Zero
from the top and bottom this time and
seven pixels from the left hand right
just to Pat it out from everything else
that is going on here so I've padded
that out
okay
great now this is all the input so once
again all I'm going to do is grab the
input element
okay so the actual input there's only
one in our project so I've just gone
ahead and grabbed the whole thing and
essentially let's kind of start it to
look a little bit like a message I'm
gonna go ahead and
also use box sizing border box on the
input let's give it a border of solids
RGB a transparent I'm gonna go black
and then 0.16 and make sure there's one
pixels in width let's part it out a
little bit so I'm going to do padding 16
pixels
and a margin of two
Cent okay so everything's got a margin
up two percent so that's what it looks
like at the moment now if I want this to
kind of be censored right and fit
exactly in the app itself I'm going to
have to use
flexbox on the app which we didn't do so
let's go ahead and do that I'm just
going to initialize flexbox
and then I'm going to Center everything
from left to right and also make sure
that everything's on top of each other
by adding Flex Direction column so
that's what it looks like at the moment
or fits in the app nicely and we've got
that scroll action going on and now we
also have an input let's just round off
the edges and finish styling off that
input a little bit more
so I'm just going to go border radius 5
pixels and that should be it and finally
we're nearly done and we can get to the
media stuff let's also just start these
buttons up a little bit
so all I am going to do is just grab the
button container so the class name
button container
again I'm just going to give a margin of
two percent I'm going to make sure that
the buttons are next to each other and
I'm going to position them at the End by
using justify content flex and
end okay and now I'm going to say that
any button that lives inside the button
container so that's what I've written
just now I'm going to make sure that the
text is uppercase
so there we go I'm going to pad each one
out by seven pixels and I'm also just
going to give it a border
none
and now if that button
also has the ID of get
query I'm just going to change its color
so I'm going to go with background color
RGB
2559586 to get that red that we used
before and as the Border radius I'm
actually going to round off the top left
10 pixels zero on the top right zero on
the bottom right and 10 pixels on the
bottom left and now let's do the same
for the clear chat button okay so we're
grabbing a button by the ID of clear
chat and now I'm going to swap this
round so we're going to go 0 10 pixels
10 pixels zero and let's make this
yellow so I'm just going to change these
to be one eight nine
four five
okay great and there we have it there is
our app now let's get to hooking it up
so for this let's start off with the
back and first so let's just go ahead
and go in here and let's set up our
backend so not the TSX file the index TS
file that's not going to have any jsx
first off I'm just going to put in my
API key up here we can of course move it
out
to an EnV file but let's just get this
working for now
okay so that is my API key just right
there
like that I'm just going to move that
down
now let's define the port we want to run
our backend on I'm going to say 8 000
and this is a number as we are writing
in typescript so we're going to have to
start working with types before we move
on let's just go ahead and check our
package.jsons look the same so yours
should look like this I think we have
everything in here that we need please
go ahead and check this slowly
okay and let's not also forget to import
the open AI package as that is another
one that we're going to need so npmi
open AI
great so let that do its thing and then
it should show up in here which it has
now done
great
let's carry on
next I'm going to import so now we're
using import Express as well as to uh
types so application
request and response from Express so
those are two things that we're going to
have to do
we're also going to have to import cores
from
cause
as well as import two things from open
Ai and that's configuration
and open AI API
so there we go
let's go ahead and reorder this to the
top so just like that
and I believe we need to also import
the type course so let's go ahead and do
that npmi save Dev type course so once
again let's just get up our terminal and
do npmi save Dev type course okay so
that we can work with course and
typescript and there we go so if we now
look in here I'm just going to show you
where that has gone that's gone all the
way down there
great
okay so now let's actually get to using
Express I'm going to grab Express which
is imported and call it to release all
of its wonderfulness and let's save it
as the const app and this is where we
use the application type that we just
imported from Express
so we got that now Express now lives
under the const app which means that I
can get up and use and pause course
through and call it so that we don't get
any cause error messages I'm going to do
the same for working with Jason so I'm
going to get Express and call Json so
there we go we can now work with passing
Json from the front end to the back end
in this project great
now from open AI I'm going to
essentially use these in order for us to
communicate with openai but first we
need to pass through our API key so I'm
going to create a new configuration also
an object but simply can have our API
key and we're just going to literally
cross through our API key and let's save
this as const configuration
just like that so you can use it later
on
now I'm going to essentially create a
new open AI API and just pass through
that configuration to just pass it
through into here
and save this you can say that's
whatever you want I'm going to save it
as open AI so that we can use it later
on
so great we should now be authenticated
let's get to writing our root to an
endpoint first off though I'm going to
listen out to any changes so I'm going
to pass the report the port is 8 000 I'm
going to put a callback function that's
just going to console log out
your server is running on Port and then
the
so that's all I'm going to do
so now let's write that route it's going
to be a post request as we have been
working with and then I'm just going to
let's make an endpoint let's just go
ahead and make one up you can call this
whatever you want essentially now who is
it localhost 8004 slash completions then
we're going to want to do something
and that is an async function I'm going
to post you the request and the response
and then these have types that we did
import from Express so that's the
request type and the response type
and now I'm going to try something and
catch any errors
catch error and if there are any errors
I'm just going to console
error
the error I'm also going to send
something over so rest status 500 error
for error and just send the text of
server error okay you don't have to but
that is what I have done
great
so what do we want to try well we're
going to await the open AI
create
completion or create chat completion to
be precise let's save this as the const
completion
and I'm gonna pass through whatever we
want to send to open Ai and that is the
model that we want to use in this case
it is GPT 4
and then the messages that we want to
pass through as part of the chat so the
message is should look like this you
need to put an array and each message is
symbolized by this little object right
here and then you have a role
it's going to be the user so us and then
whatever we pass through we're going to
be passing this through from the front
end though I'm going to pass that
through the body as a message so I'm
just going to go ahead and do request
body
message and because I want to only bring
back stuff as SQL requires so even if we
type uh name my dog I'm actually going
to append some text here that says
create a SQL
request to and then whatever we post
through okay so everything will be
turned into an SQL request so that is a
little cool hack for you to essentially
change every single request that we send
but on the back end okay great and that
should be part of the content
so I'm just going to put this movie on a
new line so it's easier to
wait for you
okay so that's my array and here is one
message that we're going to be sending
over and that's really it
so once we have the messages so that's
the whole object we are passing through
we're just going to send back whatever
comes back as the completion
we're going to go into the data I'm
going to get the choices
I'm going to go into that array get the
first thing to come back and get its
message so that is just the format of
the data coming back to us from the AI
I'm going to show you what this looks
like as well but first let's get to
hooking this up to the front end
so now here
let's just go ahead and make something
happen on click of this so on click I'm
just going to get
query and let's define our function get
query
so cons get query
and then I'm just going to Define it up
here I'm going to try something and
catch any errors so just like we did
previously
error
console
the error and what shall we try well
we're going to actually use the fetch
API from JavaScript and we're going to
fetch from http
localhost
8 000 so our backend that we just
created for slash completion so the
endpoint that we just wrote and of
course this is a post request so we're
gonna have to pass through some options
so let's define those options we can do
so here const options
equals
and then the method we're going to pass
through is a
post method the body
uh well we're gonna pass it through
Jason's stringifies as it's an object
and I'm just going to use the message
and let's just maybe hard code something
for now let's go ahead and
create
a table
okay so we're just hard coding it
at the moment let's also pass through
some headers though so headers
as we are working with Jason I'm just
going to pass through content
type
application
okay so those are all my options I want
to pass through
and this is an async method which means
we need to use the await keyword which
also means that a weight can't live
inside a function it can only live in a
inside async function so we add the
async keyword there
so we're going to wait for the response
of this and let's save this as something
I'm just going to go ahead and save it
as a response
and then I'm just going to for now grab
the response and get its Json so oh
that's also async which means we need to
await it
and once that comes back let's just save
this as data
so before we do much else I'm just going
to console log data just so we can see
what's coming back to us so there we go
great so we've now got the bare minimum
to get this working
so
let's go ahead and try this out I'm just
going to get the console log up to see
if we get any errors so now if I click
on the button get query we should
essentially send this message so with
the request body message
to here right request body message so
once again
this is the whole request
we're getting the body dot notation
because there's an object message and
then we're sending that through to the
open AI API with this appended to the
front
and then we should get that message back
so let's go let's click get query
there has been an arrow let's check why
so
we have not run our backend so let's do
npm Run start
back end and
so our server is now running on Port
8000 and let's try this again I'm just
going to do that to clear this
so we've clicked on it we are now
waiting for our message to come back
and great that is the message that comes
back its role is from the assistant and
the content is below is the SQL request
to create a table called and then we
have the response great so let's go
ahead and show that in here right so
let's go ahead and do that first so now
let's go ahead and go to the app TSX
file and let's use state in order to
save to the state of the app so I'm just
going to import use state from react
use State firmly act just like so and
that means that I can save this let's
save this chat I'm going to go to const
chat set chat and I'm going to start off
with this being actually an empty array
because we're going to have to add to
that array I just want to save all the
chats that we have and we know that our
chat is going to come back with a role
and content right so I'm just going to
do this again so we can see
okay there's my object it has a content
and a row so let's go ahead and Define
that interface up here I'm going to go
interface chat
data so one individual chat it's gonna
have a role and that's going to be a
string and then content is also going to
be a
string okay so I'm just defining the
types up here
so that means that I can now use this
interface to say that this will only
take things in the array that look
essentially like this object okay so I
have those types so that is what I am
doing this is some typescript for you
chat data
and make sure that's in an array so only
objects that look like this can go into
this array now great so now let's set
chat so once we get that back we'll
continue to log in the data I actually
just want to set the chat but I also
want to not override the array I want to
add to the array so for tour this I'm
just going to get the previous state I'm
just going to go ahead and call it all
the chat we can call it whatever you
like I'm going to get that array I'm
going to spill out the old chat back
into it I'm going to pass through the
new data but along with that I also
actually
so I'm just going to show you what
happens I also want to actually say what
we have been typing
so for this I'm going to also have to
save to State the value of a uh input
because at the moment we're just hard
coding that here right I don't want that
to happen so let's go ahead and do const
value of the input I'm going to change
it with set value as to use State and
let's start off with being an empty
string so let's also Define this this
being a string this should only be a
string ever at all times
so the value
we want to actually see that change in
the input so I'm just going to pass
through the value and on change of the
value
I'm going to get the event and I'm going
to use set value to change it to
whatever we are typing into the input so
that's how you would do that
great
so now that means that instead of hard
coding this I could use the value of
whatever we typed into the input to
overwrite that
okay
great
so I'm just going to show you if I
consort log value down here
so there we go so I'm just going to type
some stuff and it will change so that is
value as you can see on app GSX length
at 9 35.
so
whenever I essentially click to get a
query I get the response back from the
assistant but I also want to say what
I've been typing so I'm going to
actually create a new object
I'm going to call this user message and
I'm just going to construct an object
that looks exactly the same as the chat
response so we'll have a role and I'm
also going to have content for my role
I'm going to hard code AS
user because it's me and the content is
just going to be the value of what I've
sent over
so that is now my user message and I
also want to pass that through into the
search Chat array
great so now if I console log chats I'm
just going to show you what that looks
like it's just refresh so we clear that
create a table for users
get query so it's empty at the moment
our chart is empty but what do we expect
to happen when I expect two objects to
come back one from the API with the role
of assistant and one that I added in the
front end right with the role of user
and there we go
so indeed we have the role from the
assistant and the assistant says was
just giving us the text uh of how to
create a table and then me I've
hard-coded user and the content is
exactly what I wrote in here
wonderful so we're saving all of that if
I was to write another one then those
two more objects should be saved in here
each time we're saving two objects so
now let's use this data to display it
so all I am going to do is actually
go ahead and well let's filter some of
these messages right so I'm going to get
the chat and I'm going to filter
each message so each object message and
I'm going to say if the message
row equals
user then do we know the my messages so
let's say this is const filtered user
messages just like so and now I'm just
going to pause those filtered messages
into the message display so user
messages is going to be the prop I'm
just going to pass referral to do some
messages
which means that now on message display
messages display sorry plural I can pass
that through
and as this is typescript we're going to
have to Define this props so interface
messages
play
props
and well we can actually also go further
and Define the user messages interface
so interface so just defining what the
object really looks like user message
has a role
that is a string
interface
and also content right that is a string
so we know that the user message is
going to be array of this so user
messages so the prop user messages right
the properties and messages is going to
be a user message but it's going to be
array of them so that's what I've
written that
so hopefully that makes sense and now we
could just
use this to define the props we are
passing through so this will essentially
say What types all our props have we
only have one prop
okay and it's made up of this those
things in an array
cool so now we don't need to hard code
this anymore I'm actually going to get
the user messages
okay and I'm going to map so I'm going
to use dot map to map each user message
let's go with singular onto a message
display
cool
we should really have a key here too so
I'm just going to use the index for this
just because we don't want any errors
showing up maybe I'll just put this on a
new line so I'm going to have a key
that's essentially the index and then
I'm just going to pass through the
message itself as the
user message which means we now need to
go to the message display
and pass down the message
okay so let's destructure the message
the message is easy because we know what
it's going to look like we can
essentially just Define the message
props for this easily so interface
message
display props and the props for this or
the message looks like this is an object
that has a raw
or in fact what we can do is just grab
this user message again
up here and then just use the user
message okay we're just defining that
even further interface
great
so now let's grab those props
and just do that
wonderful so this is looking so so good
and now that we have each message the
message that has a role and content I
can grab the message and I can use curly
braces and get the messages
roll and display it and also get the
messages content and displayed we are
getting some curly lines here why is
that
uh we seem to have missed
parenthesis and there we go so if we
look in here now we get the user and
create table for users perhaps I don't
really want that user showing up but if
you do you can I'm just going to comment
that out form now and there we go
I'm also just going to add in a text
symbol for the icon itself so here is my
text symbol that I have chosen if you
want it to it's going to show you where
to get it from you can essentially get
it from here so there is the URL if you
want to get it
great so this is looking good to create
a table for users
um create a table for dogs I don't
really know let's just go ahead and do
that and that should be added up here
and we are only saving the messages that
have the row of user as we filter them
out
wonderful
so that's what I have done now this is
looking so so good the next thing I want
to do is just get the last possible
content of the message that has the role
of assistant to show up here so let's go
ahead and do that
so back on the app itself I am actually
going to filter once more because I'm
going to have to filter out the chat so
let's get the chat to use filter once
more to filter out each message and if
the message raw this time equals
assistant
so anything that comes back from open AI
I just want to get the very last one so
I'm just going to use pop the method of
Pops you get the very last one and
that's the latest now we can pull it
code so latest code even though
technically it's a string so once we
have the latest thing that's come back
to us from the AI I'm simply going to
pass that through so the text that we're
going to use for this is going to be the
latest code and we're not we don't need
this role we just want it
okay so we're going to display that
or if that doesn't exist I'm just going
to display an empty string
cool
so now let's pass through the protects
on the code display so let's get up our
code display
and let's pass that through
okay so this time we are not passing
through the whole object we're literally
just passing through the string that's
attached to the content
right we're going in here we're
filtering out everything by the role of
assistant so there should only be two
items in our array and I'm literally
just going dot annotation content so I'm
passing through the last this one right
we're passing through the last one that
came back to us
so let's define that prop
interface code display
props
text
string
okay so now we can just use that to
Define the types of our props
wonderful and now I could just get that
text and display it in
so there we go latest code is possibly
undefined that is fine let's check if it
exists and then also this needs to be
content great so that should show up
however
feel that we haven't changed the text of
this so let's just change the color of
this text
so on the code display let's actually
get the code output as well where it was
the code
related stuff
code display I'm also just going to grab
the code output let's give it a margin
20 pixels and I'm also going to say that
any P element that is inside
the code outputs is going to have a
different text color and I'm just going
to make it the yellow that we have been
using so 255
189 45
great so there we go that is now showing
up we've nearly done it the last thing
we'll do is just clear the chat so let's
write a function for that so let's go
ahead and do that here on click this is
going to be super easy I'm just going to
clear
chat and let's define that up here
const clear chat
there we go
all I'm going to do is set the value to
be an empty string again
so let's just put that in here and pass
through an empty string and I'm going to
set the chat to be an empty array again
so we can start fresh so let's check
that out
let's do this here
let's get that query and that should be
saved up there as part of our history
okay that is wonderful and we also get
the query to do this
let's do create a table called users and
get that query
so once again that should
do its thing
and there we go let's go ahead and do a
few more
update the table to have
a phone
numbers
okay so that hasn't done it but it's
given us some instructions and add a
fake user to the table users
and there we go it's showing us how and
we can of course scroll through all of
this and if I click on clear chat that
has cleared our chat for us great one
final thing we're going to do just to
make sure that everything is safe is
just create a DOT EnV file so we can
keep our
API key say so let's add that in here
let's do API key equals and let's get it
from the back end so index TS there we
go I'm just going to grab this it is a
string so that is implied I'm going to
use process EnV to look in that dot EnV
file and get the API key
so that's what we have done and then in
the API key here I'm just going to save
that in here like so so we are done with
this and we're just going to have to
import the dot tnv package okay so once
again I'm just going to get on my
terminal and we do npmi
dot e and V just like so okay
great
and finally we just need to import that
up here so import
like so and then let's get dot EnV and
get config and call it
okay in order to
[Music]
use it
and great that's it I hope you've
learned a lot I've really enjoyed
showing you how to do this in typescript
so I hope you had fun and I hope to see
you again soon
phew so by the end of this course you
would have learned how to create
completions using the text completion
endpoint create chats using the chat
completion endpoint and create images
from prompts as well as already existing
images thanks to the dolly model as well
so this really has been a lot hopefully
you've managed to get through some of
the projects too and if you didn't don't
worry you can always come back to this
course whenever if you wish if you did
enjoy this course and would like to
contribute to Free cocam as a thank you
please do check out the video
description below
okay everyone and that is it thank you
so much for watching along with me I
hope you've learned something useful and
I hope you enjoy using the open AI API